GOOD MORNING WILL START TODAY'S.
HEARING THIS IS THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
FINANCE TODAY WE'RE GOING TO BE
DISCUSSING.
A HASTINGS COLLEGE OF LAW.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY IN
THE CALIFORNIA'S TO NEED
COMMISSION.
IN A REVERSE ORDER SO FIRST
ISSUE WE'RE GOING TO HEAR IS
THAT.
IS THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION
AND WE KNOW THE GOVERNOR HAS TO
PROPOSALS IN THE BUDGET THAT
DROP BUT JANUARY BUDGET TO
EXPAND FINANCIAL AID.
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT ARE
SUBCOMMITTEE HAS DISCUSSED FOR A
FEW YEARS NOW AND WE'RE THINK
WHERE IT FINALLY AT A PLACE FOR
ONE AND TAKE SOME ACTION TO
REALLY LOOK AT REVAMPING OUR
FINANCIAL AID.
SYSTEM A MODERNIZING THAT
CALTRAIN THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAMS TO TO MAKE
THEM EASIER TO NAVIGATE AND
FRANKLY LOOK AT THE STUDENTS WHO
ARE JUST MISSING OUT BECAUSE OF
SOME.
ARBITRARY CUT OFF POINTS AS WELL
AS LOOKING AT THE TOTAL COST OF
TUITION AND HOW FINANCIAL AID --
DEALS WITH THAT WOULD STUDENTS
IN THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY.
SO WE'LL BE TALKING ABOUT A FEW
PROPOSALS THAT WE HAVE -- THIS
YEAR.
AND THE CA COMMISSION WALK US
THROUGH SOME OF THE COST
ESTIMATES FOR THAT -- WE'RE ALSO
GOING TO OF COURSE TALK ABOUT
OUR STATE LIBRARY SYSTEM AND HOW
THEY COULD.
BETTER SERVE OUR COMMUNITIES
ESPECIALLY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
AND FINALLY HEARING FROM.
HASTINGS.
COLLEGE OF LAW ABOUT SOME OF
THEIR ISSUES SPECIFICALLY SOME
OF THEIR BUDGET -- CONCERNS
WITHIN ROMAN HOW THEY PLAN ON
MOVING FORWARD -- SO WITH THAT
LET'S BEGIN WITH THE STUDENT
COMMISSION ITEMS.
ISSUE NUMBER ONE IS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL RELATED.
FIRST BE OFFERING.
ISSUE NUMBER ONE IS THE IS THE
PROPOSAL FROM THE GOVERNOR ON
STUDENTS WITH DEPENDENT CHILDREN
AND INCREASED FINANCIAL AID
AWARDS.
YES DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
BEACH AND MARRY OUR DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE -- JUST TO GIVE YOU A
HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES TOTAL
FINANCIAL AID EXPENDITURES OF
JUST OVER TWO POINT SEVEN
BILLION.
AS YOUR AGENDA NOTES THAT THE
COMBINATION OF ONE POINT SIX
BILLION GENERAL FUND AND ONE
POINT ONE BILLION AND
REIMBURSEMENTS THE LARGEST SHARE
OF WHICH IS TEMPORARY ASSISTANCE
FOR NEEDY FAMILIES ARE TAN F..
AND OF COURSE -- EVEN THOUGH
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE ISSUES
WERE HAPPY TO DISCUSS ANY OF THE
ESTIMATES THAT ARE INCLUDED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
THE FIRST ISSUE THAT YOUR AGENDA
NOTES AS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL FOR A NEW NON TUITION
GRANT TO ASSIST CAL GRANT
RECIPIENTS FOR STUDENTS WITH
DEPENDENT CHILDREN AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY AND
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AT A COST
OF ONE OF ONE HUNDRED TWENTY ONE
POINT SIX MILLION ONGOING
GENERAL FUND.
THESE NEW AWARDS WILL BE UP TO
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR CAL
GRANT A AND B. STUDENTS
REFLECTING AN INCREASE TO THE
ACCESS AWARD THAT BE STUDENTS
ALREADY RECEIVE.
UP TO FOUR THOUSAND FOR CAL
GRANT SEE STUDENTS.
THIS PROPOSAL IS GUIDED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION'S GOAL OF
TACKLING INTER GENERATIONAL
POVERTY BY SUPPORTING STUDENT
PARENTS IN THEIR PERSISTENCE IN
HIGHER EDUCATION.
THANK YOU AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU LA A THANK YOU
MISTER KING WITH LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
I'LL BE SPEAKING FROM YOUR TEN
DAY STARTING AT THE TOP OF PAGE.
THREE AS THE SUBCOMMITTEE KNOWS
WHILE STUDENTS FACE NOT ONLY
TUITION COSTS BUT ALSO IN ON
TUITION COSTS ASSOCIATED FOOD
HOUSING TRANSPORTATION AND OTHER.
LIVING EXPENSES.
THE STATE DOES CURRENTLYPROVIDE
SOME NON TUITION COVERAGE
THROUGH A WIDE CENTER BULLETIN
OUT IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS PAGE
HERE.
SPECIFICALLY A COW CAN'T BE
RECIPIENTS RECEIVE ACCESS AWARD
OF JUST OVER SIXTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS A YEAR.
AND HOW CAN SEE RECIPIENTS
RECEIVE A SMALLER BOOK AND
SUPPLY A WIDE AMY IS A LIVING
EXPENSES.
THERE IS SOME VARIATION IN THE
LIVING EXPENSES AT DIFFERENT
STUDENTS FACE SEND ONE SOURCE OF
POTENTIAL VARIATION IS THAT
STUDENTS WHO HAVE DEPENDENT
CHILDREN STUDENT PARENTS.
LIKELY FACE HIGHER COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH FOOD PERHAPS
HOUSING LIKELY CHILD CARE.
IMPORTANTLY STUDENT PARENTS ARE
NOT NECESSARILY GUARANTEED A CAL
GRANT AS YOU'LL SEE AT THE TOP
OF PAGE FOR MOST STUDENTS
PARENTS ARE SERVED BY THE
COMPETITIVE AWARD PROGRAM.
AND BECAUSE OF THE LIMITED
NUMBER OF COMPETITIVE AWARDS
AVAILABLE THAT MEANS THAT ONLY A
SMALL SHARE OF THOSE WHO ARE
FINANCIALLY ELIGIBLE FOR IT HOW
CAN.
GO ON TO RECEIVE.
AS THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES
NOTED THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY TWO MILLION ON GOING TO
PROVIDE.
ADDITIONAL NON TUITION COVERAGE
FOR STUDENTS PARENTS.
OUR SYSTEM OF THIS PROPOSAL.
BEGINS ON PAGE FIVE OF YOUR
AGENDA.
WE GET THE GOVERNOR IDENTIFIES A
POTENTIALLY IMPORTANT AREA OF
NEED.
THIS SUB GROUP OF STUDENTS WHOSE
FINANCIAL NEEDS ARE LIKELY NOT
MET BY OUR CURRENT SYSTEM.
THAT BEING SAID WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF CONCERNS WITH HOW THE
PROPOSAL IS CURRENTLY STRUCTURED.
THE FIRST OF THOSE CONCERNS IS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS OVER
THE PAST FEW YEARS.
EXPRESSED AN INTEREST IN
SIMPLIFYING THE COW CAN SYSTEM.
AND STREAMLINING THE VARIOUS
RULES AFFECTING ELIGIBILITY IN A
WIDE.
FIVE WE THINK THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WOULD ACT COUNTER TO
THE SUBJECTIVE BY INTRODUCING A
NEW SET OF RULES THAT ONLY
IMPACT ONE SUBGROUP OF
FINANCIALLY NEEDY STUDENTS OF
COMPLICATING THE SYSTEM FOR
STUDENTS TO NAVIGATE.
TURN THE PAGE ALSO SEE THAT WE
HAVE A RELATED DISTRIBUTIONAL
CONCERN.
WHAT IS STUDENT HAS CHILDREN IS
ONE PART OF THEIR OVERALL
FINANCIAL NEED?
OTHER MAJOR FACTORS THAT MIGHT
SHAPE THAT NEED INCLUDE THE
STUDENTS HOUSEHOLD INCOME ASSET
SIZE AND SO FORTH.
WE ARE CONCERNED THAT BY A
PRIORITIZE NEED ACCORDING TO ONE
COMPONENT OF THE OVERALL NEED
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL COULD
LEAVE OUT SOME PARTICULARLY
NEEDY STUDENTS INCLUDING SME OF
WHOM HAVE ZERO EXPECTED FAMILY
CONTRIBUTION TO THE COLLEGE
COSTS.
BASED ON THAT PANEL STATUS.
IT IS ALSO WORTH NOTING THAT.
MANY STUDENTS PARENTS WOULD NOT
RECEIVE ADDITIONAL AID UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR THE
REASON WE DISCUSSED EARLIER.
WHICH IS THE MOST STUDENT
PARENTS ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR THE
ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM AND THE
SMITH COMPETE FOR A LIMITED
NUMBER OF COMPATIBLE WITH.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WOULD
NOT PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
ASSISTANCE THE STUDENTS WERE
ELIGIBLE FOR BUT NOT OFFERED A
COMPETITIVE AWARD.
IT ALSO WOULD NOT PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE FOR
STUDENTS PARENTS OF THE PRIVATE
SECTOR SICE REGARDLESS OF THEIR
LEVEL OF FINANCIAL NEED. FOR
THESE REASONS WE DO RECOMMEND
REJECTING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL BUT WE KNOW ONCE AGAIN
THAT.
THIS PROPOSAL RAISES IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER OUR
CURRENT SYSTEMS ARE MEETING THE
NEEDS OF STUDENTS PARENTS.
AND SO THE LEGISLATURE MAY WISH
TO PROVIDE TO PURSUE FURTHER
STUDY OF THIS TOPIC.
IF SO THAT WOULD INVOLVE BETTER
UNDERSTANDING NOT ONLY THE
PARTICULAR COSTS THAT STUDENT
PARENTS FACE BUT ALSO THE LEVEL
SUPPORT CURRENTLY AVAILABLE TO
THEM THROUGH.
BOTH THE STATE'S FINANCIAL AID
SYSTEM AND EXISTING SOCIAL
SERVICES SUCH AS COMPRESSION
CALLING.
THANK YOU I'D BE HAPPY TO TAKE
IN QUESTION.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS DAVID O'BRIEN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION -- WE JUST WANT TO
NOTE THAT -- FROM OUR VANTAGE
POINT IT IS SIGNIFICANT TO THE
ADMINISTRATION RECOGNIZES AS
WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING AS WE WILL
DISCUSS LATER IN THIS HEARING
THAT THE CHANGING DEMOGRAPHIC OF
TODAY'S STUDENT -- CREATES
CHANGING NEEDS AMONG TODAY'S
STUDENTS AND THE US -- I NEED TO
MAKE SURE FINANCIALLY SYSTEM
STAYS UP TO DATE SO WHILE WE'RE
NOT WEIGHING IN WITH AN OFFICIAL
SUPPORT OPPOSE TYPE POSITION --
ON THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL
WOULD KNOW THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT -- THE RESEARCH
CONSISTENTLY SHOWS THAT STUDENTS
PARENTS FACE -- EXCEPTIONALLY
HIGH COSTS AND WE WOULD JUST SAY
THAT -- WE APPRECIATE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS RECOGNIZE THE
NEEDS OF THIS POPULATION AND AS
PART OF OUR ONGOING EFFORTS TO
ENSURE THAT ADULT LEARNERS
RETURNING STUDENTS.
CAN'T AFFORD AN ACCESS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION -- THIS PROPOSAL IS
CONSISTENT WITH THOSE GOALS OF
PEOPLE WE KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION IS FOR FORT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ALREADY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
STRUGGLE -- MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENT AT
THE BEGINNING THE HEARING WHERE
AND YOU STATED.
THEIR DESIRE TO LOOK AT
SIMPLIFYING THE PROCESS TO SEE
KATE.
I THINK THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE AS I LOOK BACK AND I
I'VE BEEN WATCHING THIS FOR A
COUPLE YEARS WE HAVE THIS.
YOU KNOW AND THIS MAY SOUND LIKE
A SLIGHT BUT IT'S NOT BUT WE
HAVE THIS STUDENT AID INDUSTRIAL
COMPLEX.
WHICH IS VERY -- VERY COMPLEX.
FOR STUDENTS TO TO TO MATCH NAY
THROUGH MYSELF AS A STUDENT MANY
YEARS AGO I FOUND IT.
VERY DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT WAS AVAILABLE TO ME IF
ANYTHING WAS AVAILABLE TO ME SO
I JUST IGNORED IT BECAUSE IT WAS
SO COMPLEX.
HI I WAS WORKING.
IN FULL TIME AT THAT POINT --
AND GOING ALONG THE STATE -- BUT
AGAIN I I APPRECIATE THAT AND
AGAIN I I JUST I AM.
WHAT I'M HEARING FROM MIDDLE
CLASS FAMILIES IS IS WHERE'S THE
SUPPORT FOR THEM I KNOW WE HAVE
THE MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP?
WHICH IS DONE IN A FROM A BROAD
PERSPECTIVE AYE AYE AYE WE NEED
TO SUPPORT THAT WE NEED A SPORT
THAT MORE.
WE DIDN'T MAKE SURE THAT
STUDENTS ARE GETTING -- A GOOD
SHARE -- GOOD A DECENT NOW.
ENOUGH MONEY TO SUPPORT YOUR
AVERAGE GETS THROUGH SCHOOL AND
IN AN EXPEDITIOUS FASHION SO I'M
REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT.
THE MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP IS
ONE HERE FROM AN A PLUS PARENTS
AS THEY FEEL LIKE.
YOU KNOW THERE'S SHE WHO WHO
SUPPORTING THEM.
BECAUSE WHEN YOU'VE GOT A FAMILY
EVEN THOUGH YOU'RE MIDDLE CLASS --
SEE ISSUE OR YOU SEE A EDUCATION
IS VERY EXPENSIVE.
SO AGAIN I WANT TO BE A
SUPPORTIVE OF THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP.
MAKE SURE THAT DOESN'T GET HE
WROTE IT IN ANY FASHION AND IN
FACT SUPPORT THAT AS WE GO
FORWARD TO MAKE MORE MONEY
AVAILABLE -- YOU KNOW THE RICH
CAN AFFORD IT WE KNOW THAT HI
BUT I THINK YOU KNOW I I HEAR A
LOT OF MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES
AFTER HER VERY FRUSTRATED WITH
GOVERNMENT.
AND I THINK THAT'S CERTAINLY
BLOOD IN OUR POLITICAL ARENA
TODAY BECAUSE THEY FEEL LIKE YOU
KNOW THIS STATE DOESN'T WATCH
OUT FOR THEM.
AND SOMETIMES I THINK THAT'S
TRUE SO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE
SUPPORT THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP GOING FORWARD.
AND IN FACT EXPAND IT WITHOUT A
TURN IT BACK TO YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL THAT
YOU MAKES AN GREAT POINTS IT
WILL BE DISCUSSING THOSE IN
GREATER LENGTH ISSUE -- NUMBER.
FIVE BUT I I GUESS THIS DOES
RAISE THAT SAME ISSUE WHICH
MISTER O'DONNELL STATES AS WE'RE
TRYING -- TO SIMPLIFY THE CAL
RANT MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP.
AND NOT HAVE ASMANY CARVE OUT
SO THIS IS ESSENTIALLY CARVE OUT
THIS THING THIS CAL GRANT
PROGRAM HAS.
IT'S LISTED IN THE AD CODE -- AN
INSANE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE YES YOU
CAN APPLY FOR THIS YOU GET AFTER
THIS BUT NOT THIS PERSON THAT
PERSON.
AND THAT'S WERE TRYING TO GO THE
OPPOSITE DIRECTION WITH THAT NOT
THAT'S NOT TO SAY IT'S NOT
IMPORTANT TO LOOK AT STUDENTS
WHO ARE PARENTS BUT YOU KNOW
THIS GOES THE MAJORITY THIS GOES
TO STUDENTS IN THE COMPETITIVE.
GRANT AND YOU HAVE TO SUCH A WIN
THE LOTTERY. TO GET A
COMPETITIVE GRANT YOU YOUR ODDS
ARE ONE IN FIFTEEN SO DIRECT.
THEY'RE ABOUT CS YES -- 67%
CHANCE.
AND SO THOSE STUDENTS ALREADY
WON THE LOTTERY SO THEY'RE
GETTING A SECOND LOTTERY.
WINNING BY THIS WERE SOME SINCE
YOU DIDN'T GET BETTER IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
THAT I DON'T HAVE A CHANCE TO
COMPETE FOR THIS -- THIS THAT
THIS PARENT GRANT SO I THINK
THOSE ARE SOME QUESTIONS WE
DON'T WANT TO MINIMIZE THE
IMPACT -- IN THE COST BIRTH
PARENTS GOING TO COLLEGE AND YOU
KNOW IT'S GETTING HARDER AND
HARDER I CAN'T I DON'T EVEN I
CAN IMAGINE THAT. THIRTY YEARS
AGO MY MY LATE MOTHER HAD FOUR
KIDS.
WORK AT A BANK TWO BLOCKS FROM
HERE.
AND WAS A SINGLE MOM AND WENT TO
SCHOOL AT NIGHT.
AND WORK DURING THE DAY AND
RAISED FOUR KIDS ON OUR OWN.
AND THAT SHE WAS ABLE TO DO IT
WITH THE FINANCIAL WITH THE CAL
GRANT EQUIVALENT BACK THEN AND
NOW NO WAY.
THE DECK IS STACKED AGAINST YOU
SO MUCH THAT I DON'T EVEN.
UNDERSTAND HOW SOME OF THESE --
THESE THESE THAT STUDENTS AND
STUDENTS TO A PARENT'S MULTIPLE
KIDS AND ONE KID OF WHAT HAVE
YOU.
CAN MANAGE THE THE COST OF THE
FINANCIAL AID -- THE SYSTEM HERE
IN CALIFORNIA SO YOU KNOW THIS
IS ENTERING PROPOSAL WE'RE GOING
TO HOLD UP AND WE WANT TO
EVALUATE THIS IN TOTALITY.
OF THE OTHER CAL GRANT -- IDEAS
WE HAVE.
IN THE IN THE BUDGET SO -- WILL
PRESENT WILL PROCEED WITH ISSUE
NUMBER TWO NOW ABOUT THE
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT PROPOSAL.
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES
FUNDING FOUR THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY NEW CAL GRANT
COMPETITIVE AWARDS ANNUALLY AT A
COST OF NINE POINT SIX MILLION
ON GOING GENERAL FUND.
THE COMPETITIVE PROGRAM IS
AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS WHO ARE IN
ELIGIBLE FOR AN ENTITLEMENT
OUTLINED BY THE COMMISSION.
SO WITH THIS INCREASE THE AMOUNT
OF ANNUAL COMPETITIVE AWARDS
WILL RAISE FROM 250-007-0050 TWO
THIRTY THOUSAND ANNUALLY.
OKAY LA A THANK YOU.
AS WE JUST DISCUSSED ONLY A
SMALL SHARE OF STUDENTS WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR COMPETITIVE CAL
GRANT CURRENTLY RECEIVE AN AWARD
OFFER BECAUSE OF THE LIMIT ON
AVAILABLE WARRANT.
FOR THIS MEANS THAT IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN THERE WERE
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED NINETY
THOUSAND ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS FOR
COMPETITIVE AWARDS WHO WERE NOT
OFFERED.
ONE AND THOSE ELIGIBLE NON ORTIZ
HAD AN AVERAGE INCOME OF ABOUT
TWENTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THIS IS JUST A SAID THERE IS A
LARGE AMOUNT OF UNMET DEMAND IN
THE COMPETITIVE PROGRAM.
AMONG STUDENTS WHO HAVE HIGH
FINANCIAL NEED.
GIVEN THAT WE DO THINK THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS
REASONABLE.
IF LEGISLATURE WISHES TO AUGMENT
FUNDING FOR THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM.
WE RECOMMEND PRIORITIZING THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR DAVID O'BRIEN AT
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION -- AS
YOU MENTIONED AND ECHOING WITH
THE LA ON THE PARTNER FINANCES
SAID THE COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM IS -- MASSIVELY
OVERSUBSCRIBED BE AVAILABLE
NUMBER OF AWARDS IS NOT REMOTELY
KEPT UP WITH THE DEMAND AND THIS
IS THE PRIMARY FINANCIALLY
PROGRAM THAT SERVES -- WHAT WE
ONCE CALLED NONTRADITIONAL
STUDENTS THAT ARE INCREASINGLY
BECOMING SORT OF THE NEW NORMAL --
ADULT LEARNERS AND RETURNING
STUDENTS IN A PARTICULAR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS SO --
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
AVAILABLE WORDS IS VERY MUCH A
PRIORITY FOR US OF THE
COMMISSION.
YES SO THIS IS A BIG PRIORITY OF
THE COMMITTEE AS WELL WE'VE
TRIED LAST YEAR'S TO INCREASE
THAT THE NUMBER OF COMPETITIVE
AWARDS SAID.
MAKE IT MORE LIKELY THAT.
THAT -- THE ONE IN.
FIFTEEN A RATIO -- CHANGES.
WHAT'S THE TOTAL NUMBER OF OF OF
COMPETITIVE AWARDS WE WOULD NEED
TO TO TO FULLY FUND ELIGIBILITY --
TYPICALLY IT'S OVER -- THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND FINANCIALLY
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS APPLY EVERY
YEAR I FIND IT'S TWENTY
SOMETHING THOUSAND RIGHT TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY YEAH THIS WILL GET US THIS
WE GET FOUR THOUSAND MORE.
TO THE THREE TO THIRTY THOUSAND
CORRECT YEAH SO THE QUESTION
THAT KIND OF WITH A SIMILAR
ISSUE BEFORE IS THAT.
PARENTS REPRESENT ROUGHLY 9% OF
CAL RENT RECIPIENTS ACCORDING TO
THE AGENDA.
AND SO THE 9% WHO GET THE
COMPETITIVE FOR ACOSTA BOB AND
THERE'S A BUNCH AT 91% OF NOT
THE MATHIS QUITE WORK BUT A HUGE
NUMBER OF A PROBABLY STUDENT.
PERRANCE THE PLIGHT FOR THE
COMPETITIVE DID EVEN GET THE
COMPETITIVE.
SO SHE SAID THIS TO THE STUDENT
COMMISSIONER LA L. CAN THINK
THAT WE SHOULD CONSIDER.
I'M USING THATTO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF COMPETITIVE EVEN
TARGET COMPETITORS FOR STUDENTS
WHO ARE PARENTS.
I WILL BE FROM THE COMMISSION
PERSPECTIVE WE HAD NECESSARILY.
THOUGHT ABOUT DOING A TARGET
WITHIN THE COMPETITIVE PROGRAM --
WE'VE TENDED TO TAKE MORE OF A
BLANKET POSITION THAT ANY
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
AVAILABLE WORDS.
IS YOU KNOW A GOOD THING AND
THAT WE WOULD SUPPORT IT AND
THAT IT WOULD HAVE THOSE SORT OF
RIPPLE POSITIVE AFFECTS -- SO I
WILL JUST SAY THAT -- WHILE WE
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE ARE UNIQUE
POPULATIONS THAT HAVE.
SPECIFIC NEEDS SUCH AS STUDENT
PARENTS I DON'T THINK THAT
WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF A
COMPETITIVE PROGRAM WE HAVE
CONSIDERED WHETHER OR NOT THERE
SHOULD BE SOME SORT OF SPECIFIC
TARGETING JUST YET [inaudible]
IS THAT.
IN OUR SYSTEM WE DID CONSIDER
THAT THE LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
COMPETITIVE AWARDS BY EVEN MORE
THAN WHAT TO INCLUDE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
CONSERVING COULD EARN ALICE'S
SYSTEM PLAST MEANT THAT EVERY
ADDITIONAL ONE MILLION DOLLARS
WOULD ALLOW THE STATE AUTHORIZED
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY
EIGHT ADDITIONAL ACCESS TO WHERE
IT'S THAT BEING SAID I BELIEVE
THAT IN ISSUE FIVE OF THE AGENDA
TODAY THERE'LL BE A PRESENTATION
ON FURTHER COST ESTIMATES TO
TAKE.
INTO ACCOUNT FOR EXAMPLE THE
COST OF ADDITIONAL RENEW AWARDS
FROM EXPANDING THE PROGRAM
CORRECT SO WE DO WANT.
TO EXPLORE THIS COMPETITIVE
ISSUE AND HAVING MORE AWARDS AND
POTENTIALLY -- ADJUSTING THE THE
THE AGE REQUIREMENT FOR
COMPETITIVE FIRST ENTITLEMENT IN
MORE WE'LL GET TO THAT.
IN A IN A FEW MOMENTS SO WITH
THAT WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN
LESS ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SING NINE SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER THREE GRANT
DELIVERY SYSTEM MODERNIZATION.
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES SIX
POINT TWO MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND FOR THE SECOND YEAR
OF PROJECT COSTS. FOR THE
COMMISSION'S GRANT DELIVERY
SYSTEM MODERNIZATION PROJECT
FINANCE IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY CONTINUE TO MONITOR
THE PROJECT REGULARLY AND CAN
SAY THAT THE PROJECT IS
CURRENTLY ON TIME AND ON BUDGET.
JUST NEED COMMISSION IS
CURRENTLY IN ITS FIRST YEAR OF
THAT CAN'T DELIVERY SYSTEM
MODERNIZATION PROJECT AND BASS
MARV YOU BECOME CARELESS
DEPARTMENT FINANCE THIS PROJECT
IS GENERALLY ON SCHEDULE AND
WITHIN BUDGET.
AS THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
NOTED THIS PROJECT IS ALSO
RECEIVING OVERSIGHT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY.
WHO IS CONSISTENTLY PROVIDED AT
WAVE POSITIVE RATINGS ON A
MONTHLY BASIS FOR THESE REASONS
WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
TO FIGHT A SECONDARY FUNDING FOR
THIS PROJECT?
CURRENTLY THE STATE NEED
COMMISSION ANTICIPATES
COMPLETING THIS PROJECT DURING
THE TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FISCAL YEAR AND SO WE ANTICIPATE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE MAY HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITY TO FIGHT
OVERSIGHT AS PART OF NEXT YEAR'S
BUDGET PROCESS.
THANK YOU.
SO THIS IS THE FINAL PAYMENT.
THIS IS THE FINAL YEAR OF
PROJECTS SET UP COSTS -- AND
THEN THERE WILL BE SOME
MAINTENANCE SOME OPERATIONS
COSTS AND THE THEREAFTER MY
COLLEAGUE RENDER BEINGS WHOSE
OUR CHIEF INFORMATION OFFICER.
CAN ANSWER ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
YEAH BUT I JUST WANT TO NOTE FOR
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
MINISTRATION -- AND THE ALIENS
RECOMMENDATION FOR THEIR SUPPORT
AT THIS CRUCIAL PROJECT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
GOOD MORNING ARE YOU HERE FOR
QUESTIONS OR YOUR SERVERS AT
QUESTIONS OKAY THANK YOU.
I'M NOT I DO NOT HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS I KNOW WE HAVE
DISCUSSED THIS -- FOR DISLEY THE
FIFTH BUDGET YEAR THAT I'VE BEEN
HERE WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THIS
AND SO -- OF COURSE WE HAVE THE
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE LA -- AS
WELL.
AND I THINK A LOT OF THIS WAS AT
THE EARLY STAGES OF GO NO GO SO --
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE -- WE WILL.
APPROVED THIS -- AFTER THE FINAL
REVISION SELLER HOLD THIS ISSUE
UP.
ISSUE NUMBER FOR STATE OPERATION
SUPPORTS.
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES
THREE HUNDRED NINETY THOUSAND
GENERAL FUND OF WHICH TWO
HUNDRED NINETY THOUSAND IS
ONGOING AND THREE PERMANENT
POSITION. TO SUPPORT THE
COMMISSION'S OPERATIONS A
HUNDRED THOUSAND IS FOR SYSTEM
UPDATES TO THE CURRENT GRANT
DELIVERY SYSTEM TO ACCOUNT FOR
RECENTLY ENACTED LEGISLATION
EXPANDING CAL GRANT B. AND
CHAFEE GRANT ELIGIBILITY FOR
FOSTER YOUTH.
OF THE THREE POSITIONS TO EIGHT
TO ASSOCIATE GOVERNMENTAL
PROGRAM ANALYSTS WILL BE
PROVIDED TO THE INSTITUTIONAL
SUPPORT DIVISION AND ONE OFFICE
TECHNICIAN WILL BE PROVIDED TO
SUPPORT THE EXECUTIVE STAFF AT
THE CONNECTION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'LL BE DISCUSSING THESE THREE
PROPOSALS IN THE ORDER THAT THEY
LISTED ON YOUR AGENDA STARTING
AT THE BOTTOM OF PAGE.
FOURTEEN REGARDING THE FIRST
PROPOSAL TO FIGHT ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ONE TIME TO IMPLEMENT
NEW FOSTER YOUTH ELIGIBILITY
RULES.
THE STUDENT AT COMMISSION HAS
IDENTIFIED CHANGES IT MUST MAKE
TO ITS CURRENT GRANT DELIVERY
SYSTEM IN ORDER TO IMPLEMENT
RULES CREATED AS PART OF LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET PACKAGE.
WE REVIEWED THIS REQUEST AND
FIND IT TO BE REASONABLE.
REGARDING THE SECOND PROPOSAL BY
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND ON
GOING INTO POSITIONS FOR
INSTITUTIONAL SUPPORT.
YOU NEED COMMISSION HAS
INDICATED THAT THEIR
INSTITUTIONAL SUPPORT UNIT HAS
EXPERIENCED INCREASED WORKLOAD
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS.
BASED ON OUR REVIEW OF THEIR
DATA WE FIND THAT ONE ADDITIONAL
POSITION WOULD LIKELY REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF OVERTIME THEIR
EXISTING STAFF AND INSTITUTIONAL
SUPPORT UNIT ARE WORKING AND
ALLOW THE COMMISSION.
TO MAINTAIN ITS CURRENT LEVEL OF
SERVICE.
HOWEVER THE ADMINISTRATION'S
INDICATED TO US THAT PART OF THE
INTENT IN THIS PROPOSAL IS TO
ALLOW THE INSTITUTIONAL SUPPORT
UNIT TO PROVIDE A HIGHER LEVEL
OF SERVICE.
IF THAT IS A LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITY THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WISH TO CONSIDER BOTH OF THE
PROPOSED POSSESSIONS.
IN DOING SO IT MAY ALSO WISH TO
CONSIDER PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD REQUIRE THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION REPORT ON THE
ACTIVITIES OF ITS INSTITUTIONAL
SUPPORT UNIT. TO ENSURE THAT IT
IS IN FACT HAVING THE INTENDED
THE FACT.
FINALLY REGARDING THE THIRD
PROPOSAL TO FIVE SEVENTY
THOUSAND ON GOING AND ONE
POSITION TO SUPPORT THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICE.
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION IS
CONDUCTED A WORKLOAD ANALYSIS.
ESTIMATING THE NUMBER OF HOURS
EXECUTIVE OFFICE TEAM FANS ON
ADMINISTRATIVE TASKS SUCH AS
SCHEDULING MEETINGS AND
PROCESSING TRAVEL REIMBURSEMENTS.
BASED IN OUR REVIEW OF THE
WORKLOAD ANALYSIS WE FIND THE
REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT TO BE
REASONABLE.
THANK YOU CAPITA TAKEN QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR DAVID OBRIEN
STUDENT AID COMMISSION -- I JUST
WANT -- TO ONCE AGAIN A CORE
PRECISION TO THE MINISTRATION --
FOR UNDERSTANDING THE NEED HERE
TO THE ONLY -- FOR THE
SUPPORTIVE COMMENTS -- TO TO
OFFER A SORT OF AN EDITORIAL
POINT IF I MAY UM.
WE'RE TO THIS UNIT COMMISSION
FOR A FEW YEARS NOW WE ARE NOT
BY ANY MEASURE AND OVERSTAFFED
OVER FUNDED STATE BUREAUCRACY
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES COMES IN EVERY DAY --
DEDICATED TO OUR MISSION WORKING
HARD ON BEHALF OF STUDENTS AND
AS OUR FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM
CONTINUES TO TO BE A VERY
COMPLEX.
SORT OF MULTI FACETED SYSTEMS
MEMBERS THIS COMMITTEE HAVE --
HAVE NOTED TODAY -- IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE BE ABLE TO
WORK WITH OUR INSTITUTIONS AND
OUR STUDENTS BOTH HIGH SCHOOL
AND COLLEGE INSTITUTIONS AND OUR
STUDENTS TO MAKE SURE THAT --
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS OUR
FINANCIALLY SYSTEM [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
SING ON UNLESS WILL AGAIN HOLD
THIS ISSUE OPEN.
AND FOR PROCEED NOW ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE THIS IS OUR BIG DISCUSSION
ITEM FOR TODAY.
THIS IS RELATED TO SOME REFORM
IDEAS FOR THAT.
CAL GRANT A MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM.
WHICH AS WE KNOW -- SEVERAL
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS OF PUTTING
MYSELF AND MR MEDINA -- LEADING
EFFORTS A FOCUS ON THIS THROUGH
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND OF
COURSE TODAY WE'LL TALK ABOUT
THE BUDGET IMPLICATIONS.
SO MISTER BRIAN GREAT THANK YOU
PLEASE PROCEED.
DAVID ARRIVE FOR CALIFORNIA TO
NEW COMMISSION.
ALL BY MY LONESOME UP HERE YES
AND WAY I KNOW YOU'RE WE HAVE A
NEW EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR SO WE DO
JUST READING HERE IN THIS IS
WE'RE LAST.
TIME AT THE AT THE HELM OF THE
INTERIM SO THANK YOU.
YES MY YEARS THANK YOU -- CHAIR
AND BEFORE THAT BEFORE YOU WALK
THROUGH THE PROPOSAL'S HERE CAN
YOU MAYBE JUST REMIND.
THE PUBLIC IN THE COMMITTEE
WHERE WE'VE BEEN THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS AND HOW WE GOT HERE
ABSOLUTELY ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU.
SO -- IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS IN PARTICULAR UNDER
PREVIOUS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
LIPITOR CORTES ALKALI AND OUR
CURRENT CHAIR LUNDY JOE SAY.
THE STUDENT EIGHT COMMISSION
WORKINGWITH PARTNERS SUCH AS
THE LEGISLATURE STUDENT GROUPS
AND OUR INSTITUTIONAL SIGNAL
PARTNERS.
HAS -- UNDERTAKEN SOME PRETTY
COMPREHENSIVE STUDIES AND
WORKSHOPS OF THE COMPLEXITIES OF
OUR FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM AND
LOOKING AT POTENTIAL MODELS OR
WAYS TO OVERHAUL THE SYSTEM. TO
REALLY OF MODERNIZE IT AND BRING
IT IN LINE WITH WHAT A TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY FINANCIAL AID
SYSTEM SERVING THE STUDENTS OF
TODAY WOULD LOOK LIKE AND
RECOGNIZING THAT THE SYSTEM WE
HAVE NOW -- AS AS STRONG AS IT
IS IN CHAIR YOU'VE CALLED AT THE
IN THE IN THE NATION I
ABSOLUTELY BELIEVE THAT'S
CORRECT.
IS VERY MUCH -- BUILT FOR AN
EARLIER TYPE OF STUDENT THE TYPE
OF STUDENT WHO IS MORE LIKELY TO
GO TO COLLEGE YOU'RE LIKELY AT A
HIGH SCHOOL WHO IS MORE LIKELY
TO GO DIRECTLY TO A FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTION OR TWO INTO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WHO WAS.
YOUR LIVING AT HOME AND MAYBE
WORKING PART TIME AND THE FACT
THAT MATTER IS OUR STUDENT
POPULATION HAS CHANGED.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT OUR
FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM SORT OF
KEEP UP WITH THAT TO ENSURE THAT
WE CAN MAKE THAT GOAL OF A
HIGHER EDUCATION SOMETHING
THAT'S AFFORDABLE.
AND ACCESSIBLE FOR EVERY STUDENT.
SO IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN AFTER
DIRECTION FROM THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE PREVIOUS YEAR'S BUDGET
ACT WE COMMISSIONED A STUDY THAT
THE CENTURY FOUNDATION RELEASED.
CALLED -- GOTCHA FORGETTING THAT
EVEN W. COMMISSIONED A STUDY BY
THE CENTURY FOUNDATION A TEAM
LED BY -- ROBERT CHAIRMAN AND IT
WAS AN EXCELLENT REPORT THAT WAS
RELEASED IN APRIL OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THAT RECOMMENDED A SORT
OF COST OF ATTENDANCE FOCUSED
MODEL FOR FINANCIAL AID SO.
BILL THE IDEA BEING THAT THE
SYSTEM THE FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM
SHOULD MAKE THE OVERALL COST OF
ATTENDANCE SOMETHING THAT'S
MANAGEABLE AND AFFORDABLEFOR
EVERY STUDENT.
NOT JUST FOCUS ON ENSURING THAT
STUDENTS CAN FOR THEIR TUITION
BECAUSE WE NOW -- AS THIS
COMMITTEE HAS HEARD A MANY TIMES
AND AS THE LEGISLATION THAT YOUR
CO AUTHOR MISTER CHAIR --
FOCUSES ON THINGS LIKE HOUSING
COSTS TRANSPORTATION COSTS
TEXTBOOKS EDUCATIONAL SUPPLIES
ETCETERA REALLY TO MAKE UP THE
BULK OF STUDENTS TOTAL COST --
IN THE MODERN AGE -- AT
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTIONS SO --
PURSUANT TO A STAFF REQUEST IN
MANY DISCUSSIONS THAT WE HAVE
HAD WITH YOUR STAFF AND WITH
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
LEGISLATIVE STAFF -- WHAT WE DID
AT THE STERN THE COMMISSION IS
PUT TOGETHER THIS DOCUMENT THAT
I BELIEVE YOU HAVE IT SAYS
CALIFORNIA STUDENT A COMMISSION
COST ESTIMATES AT THE TOP?
THE SORT OF LOOKS AT SOME OF THE
BUDGET ACTIONS THAT COULD BE
TAKEN -- IMMEDIATELY IF YOU WILL
SO -- RATHER THAN -- IN LIEU OF
THE LEGISLATION -- ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN OR THE OTHER
CAL GRANT REFORM LEGISLATION OUT
THERE -- TO THESE WERE SORT OF
SOME THINGS THAT COULD BE DONE
TO RIGHT AWAY IN THE CURRENT
BUDGET ACT TO KIND OF KICK OFF --
FINANCIALLY REFORM IN CALIFORNIA
SO HAPPY TO SORT OF GO THROUGH
THIS DOCUMENT TALK ABOUT WHAT
SOME OF THESE -- SOME OF THESE
PROPOSALS ARE WITH THE
DISCLAIMER OF COURSE IF I MAY OF
THAT -- BUT THESE WERE PROVIDED
FOR INFORMATIONAL PURPOSES AND
THAT THIS DOCUMENT DOES NOT
REPRESENT AN OFFICIAL POLICY
PROPOSAL OR DOOR SPENT AT THE
STUDENT A COMMISSION IS MADE.
THE SENSE THE SCORING SOME OF
THAT.
THE WELL PUBLICIZED IDEAS THAT
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT VERY
MUCH SO CERTAINLY -- AND ALSO
JUST ONE ANOTHER THIS IS NOT --
NOR IS THIS THE ENTIRE UNIVERSE
OF VARIOUS BUDGET ACTIONS OUR
CALVET REFORM I'M SECURE DEBATE
THIS IS JUST SORT OF SOME OF THE
I THINK -- COMMITTEE STAFF AND I
WORK WERE JOKING THAT IS KIND OF
LIKE THE OLD DAVID LETTERMAN TOP
TEN IF YOU WILL OF FINANCIAL AID
OR KIND OF SOME OF THE BIG
TICKET ITEMS THAT WAS DAVID
LETTERMAN ABOUT.
THESE BOOKS ARE NOT AS OLD AND A
YES.
SO.
HAPPY TO WALK THROUGH THIS.
WITH INTERESTED YES PLEASE RIGHT.
SO ONE OF THE ONE OF THE KEY
COMPONENTS THAT WE HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSING IN RECENT YEARS WITH
REGARDS TO CAL GRANT.
IS THE ACCESS WORK COMPONENT OF
OUR CAL GRANT THE PROGRAM THIS
IS THE STATE'S MAIN -- FINANCIAL
AID AWARD THAT COVERS NON
TUITION EXPENSES FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS -- IT IS -- IT'S
ACTUALLY THE ME THE ONLY CAL
GRANT AWARD THAT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS CAN RECEIVE
SENSORS NO TUITION CHARGE FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND THE
ECONOMY ACCESS THE WORD WHICH
SERVES -- OVER A QUARTER OF A
MILLION STUDENTS HAS NOT KEPT UP
WITH INFLATION IT WAS FIRST
INSTITUTED IN THE LATE NINETEEN
SIXTIES AT NINE HUNDRED DOLLARS --
IN NINETEEN SIXTY TO NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE DOLLARS SO WOULD BE
WORTH MORE THAN SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YEAR TODAY IF IT
KEPT UP WITH INFLATION.
IT'S CURRENTLY SET AT ONE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT
DOLLARS SO IT'S WORTH ABOUT A
QUARTER OF WHAT IT WOULD BE SO
WHAT WE DID IS WE JUST SORT OF
LOOKED AT SOME COST ESTIMATES IF
THE AWARD WERE TO BE INCREASED
TO TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS. TO
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS NO
ORDER THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
QUITE CANDIDLY MISTER CHAIR THIS
IS A THIS IS NOT A LOW COST --
LOW LIFT ITEM EVEN INCREASING IT
BY A FEW HUNDRED DOLLARS TO TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS WOULD COST A
LITTLE OVER A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS -- IN ANNUAL FUNDS --
AND ABOUT THE WHAT'S DALY
INCREASE YEAR OVER YEAR AS THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS RECEIVING THE
AWARD INCREASES BUT AS I SAID
THIS IS THE PRIMARY FORM OF NON
TUITION SUPPORT MEANING SUPPORT.
FOR TEXTBOOKS SUPPLIES LIVING
EXPENSES AT CETERA THAT THE
STATE PROVIDES THROUGH THE CAL
GRANT PROGRAM.
SO -- WE THINK IT WOULD PAY
SIGNIFICANT DIVIDENDS BUT AGAIN --
NOT A LOW COST.
MOVING ON SURE AND THE THIS
WOULD BE FROM THIS.
IS KIND OF GOING TO COMING TO
THE END.
THIS WOULD BE.
THE MOST COSTLY I BELIEVE SO.
YEAH OVERALLTHOUGH DEPENDING ON
SOME OF THE SOME OF THE OPTIONS
BUT YES BY AND LARGE.
SO THE OTHER THING WE TALKED
ABOUT AND THAT YOU MENTION AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE HEARING --
CHAIR MCCARTY IS THE NOTION OF
SORT OF CLOSING UP SOME OF THE
GAPS IN OUR CURRENT STATE
FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM -- AGAIN
CAL GRANT BEING -- ARGUABLY THE
MOST GENEROUS IN PROGRESS OF
FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM IN THE
COUNTRY THERE ARE STILL A LOT OF
STUDENTS THAT ARE LEFT OUT THAT
HAVE SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL NEED
THAT -- IT CERTAINLY APPEARS
WERE INTENDED TO BE SERVED BY
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM BUT THANKS
TO SOME OF THESE CARD OUTSIDE OF
IN BUILT IN OVER THE YEARS HAVE
BEEN -- UNINTENTIONALLY LEFT OUT
AND SO -- FOR EXAMPLE THANKS TO
THE FACT THAT CAL GRANT A AND
CAL GRANT BE HAVE DIFFERENT GPA
REQUIREMENTS BUT ALSO DIFFERING
INCOME CEILINGS A LOT OF
STUDENTS -- WHO HAVE WHAT IN
CALIFORNIA WOULD YOU KNOW NATION
WIDE MIGHT BE CONSIDERED MIDDLE
INCOME BUT IN CALIFORNIA --
HARDLY MIDDLE CLASS FIFTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO ABOUT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
INCOME -- DON'T RECEIVE ANY CAL
GRANT AT ALL EVEN THOUGH THEY
MAY HAVE A GPA CLOSE TO THREE
POINT NO THEY MAY GET INTO ONE
OF OUR CS YOU WERE UC CAMPUSES
ONE OF OUR QUALIFYING PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS.
BUT BECAUSE OF THIS GAP DUE TO
THE DIFFERENT GPA IN INCOME
CEILINGS DON'T GET ANY CAL GRANT
IT WHATSOEVER.
AND SO THAT'S A CLOSE TO TEN
THOUSAND STUDENTS STATEWIDE --
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER AND AT A COST
OF ABOUT FORTY EIGHT MILLION --
OR ABOUT A HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
MILLION ON GOING WINNER NEW ALL
STUDENTS ARE FACTORED IN THAT
GAP COULD BE CLOSED UP SORT OF
HELPING US BUILD A UNIFIED
STREAMLINED.
CAL GRANT SYSTEM.
ANOTHER PROVISION THAT -- WAS --
THAT HAS BEEN A LAW FOR ABOUT
FORTY YEARS NOW THAT WE DON'T
KNOW DISCUSS MUCH BUT WITH IS
SORT OF PART OF OUR VISION FOR
UNIFIED CAL GRANT SYSTEM.
IS A PROVISION IN OUR CAL GRANT
BE CODE FOR YOU KNOW WHATEVER
REASON SAYS THAT STUDENTS TO GET
A CAL GRANT BE AND GO TO ONE OF
OUR FOUR YEAR SCHOOLS THAT'S THE
UC A CSU.
OR A PRIVATE NONPROFIT OR FOR
PROFIT INSTITUTION DON'T GET A
TUITION AWARD IN THEIR FIRST
YEAR THE GET IN YEARS TWO THREE
OR FOUR BUT IN THEIR FIRST YEAR
THEY ONLY GET THAT ACCESS THE
WAR THAT SUPPORT FOR BOOKS AND
SUPPLIES.
AND AS FAR AS WERE ABLE TO TELL
THAT WAS BUILT ON OUTDATED
PROVISION OF LAW BACK IN THE DAY
THAT ASSUME THAT LOW INCOME
STUDENTS WOULD OVER WHEN WE GO
TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE FIRST AND
THEN THE ANSWER FOR NOW IS THAT
A BETTER DEAL WHEN TUITION WAS
LOWER.
CERTAINLY PEOPLE MADE THE CHOICE
TO ACTUALLY TRACK THAT BUT NOW
BUT EVERY YEARS THAT I VISION
HAS BECOME OUTDATED AND ARGUABLY
GIVEN THE STATE'S YEAH OUT
SUPPORT FOR LOW INCOME STUDENTS
ATTENDING COLLEGE -- AN
OFFENSIVE PROVISIONED YOUR TO
HAVE -- IN OUR FINANCIAL AID
SYSTEM ASSUMING THAT LOW INCOME
STUDENTS WILL AUTOMATICALLY GO
EXCLUSIVELY TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
ARE THE THIRD NOT WORTHY QUOTE
UNQUOTE OF GOING TO A FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTION.
SO THERE'S A KIND OF TO THE BIG
YOU KNOW GAPS THAT WE TALK ABOUT
OUR HOLES -- AGAIN BOTH OF WHICH
CARRIED A SIGNIFICANT PRICE TAG
OVER A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY TO CLOSE ON AND WE KNOW
THAT IN THE CASE OF THAT CAL
GRANT THE PROVISION THAT I JUST
MENTIONED -- OUR PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS -- TO APPEAR BE
COVERING MOST OF THE STUDENTS
WITH THEIR INSTITUTIONALLY BASED
FINANCIAL AID ON ANNUAL BASIS SO
FORTUNATELY DOES NOT SEEM OF
THERE'S A LOT OF STUDENTS IN
THAT PARTICULAR PROVISION THAT
ARE NOT GETTING THE TUITION
SUPPORT.
IT'S JUST THAT IT'S PART OF A
VERY COMPLEX AND DIFFICULT TO
UNDERSTAND SYSTEM WHEN THEY'RE
TUITION SUPPORT IS COMING PARTLY
FROM THE STATE PARTY FROM THE
INSTITUTION AND THEN AFTER YOUR
ONE IT'S WHICH IS FROM
INSTITUTIONAL AID TO STATE A AND
REALLY -- UNIFIED STREAMLINED
SYSTEM MIGHT COVER TUITION FOR
ALL STUDENTS FOR FOUR YEARS
[inaudible]
OKAY -- FINALLY ON THIS PAGE.
TWO MORE PAGES -- ON PAGE TWO WE
HAVE SOME -- COST ESTIMATES ARE
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT AWARDS AND
SO WE JUST LOOK AT WHAT A COST
PER AN EXTRA.
FIVE THOUSAND AWARDS EVERY YEAR
SO ADDING FIVE THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL WORDS ABOUT ELEVEN
MILLION AT THE CURRENT RATE BUT
WE ALSO LOOK AT IF THE CAL GRANT.
ACCESS THE WAR WERE TO BE
INCREASED WHAT THAT WOULD COST
BECAUSE THAT SORT OF HAS A
COMPOUNDING EFFECT.
SO AN ADDITIONAL IF YOU LOOK AT
THE BOTTOM RIGHT AN ADDITIONAL --
FIVE THOUSAND AWARDS FOR YEARS
OUT WOULD COST ABOUT TWENTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS AT THE
THREE THOUSAND RATE.
SO THOSE ARE DONE -- PER STAFF
REQUEST TO SORT OF LOOK AT THE
KIND OF COMPOUNDING -- COST
SCORING.
TOP OF PAGE -- THREE ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT -- ARE COMMISSION
HAS SUPPORTIVE IN RECENT YEARS
HAS BEEN REMOVING BARRIERS TO
STUDENTS GETTING A TRANSFER
ENTITLEMENT CAL GRANT SO THE
TRANSFER ENTITLEMENT CAL GRANT
IN OUR VIEW.
IS -- ONE OF THE SORT OF LESSER
KNOWN IN MAY BE LESSER
PUBLICIZED BUT REALLY -- MORE --
ADVANTAGEOUS PROVISIONS WERE
FINANCIALLY SYSTEM THE TRANSFER
ENTITLEMENT CAL GRANT SAYS TO
ANY STUDENT BUT IF YOU MEET THE
GPA REQUIREMENT CURRENTLY TWO
POINT FOR YOUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
AND YOU TRANSFER PRIOR TO
TURNING AGE TWENTY EIGHT AND
APPLY -- YOU CAN GET A CAL GRANT
FOR YOUR TWO YEARS AT THE FOUR
YEAR INSTITUTION AFTER YOU
TRANSFER THAT YOU'RE ENTITLED TO
THAT AND THAT WILL COVER YOUR
TUITION AND FEES AS WELL AS AN
ADDITIONAL.
AWARD FOR ACCESS COSTS IF YOU
RECEIVE A CAL GRANT BE HOWEVER.
IT HAS AN AGE LIMIT AGE TWENTY
EIGHT AS YOU ARE REFERENCE
EARLIER CHAIR SO.
THAT LEAVES OUT QUITE A FEW
STUDENTS SEVERAL THOUSAND
STUDENTS WHO ATTEND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ENTRANCE FOR A LITTLE
BIT LATER -- AGAIN SORT OF THAT
NOTION OF THE TODAY'S STUDENT
MEDIA DEMOGRAPHIC OF TODAY'S
STUDENT SO WHAT WE'VE DONE IS
SOME COST CALCULATIONS FOR IF WE
WERE TO LIFT THAT AGE LIMIT TO
AGE.
THIRTY ABOUT THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS IT'S THIRTY FIVE BY
FIFTY SEVEN MILLION.
EACH FORTY ABOUT SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION AND THEN JUST TO SAY NO
AGE RESTRICTION ANY STUDENT WHO
ATTENDS A CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TRANSFERS MEETS OUR GPA
AND ARE -- APPLICATION
REQUIREMENTS WOULD GET THAT CAL
GRANT AS AN ENTITLEMENT WHEN
THEY TRANSFER.
SO THAT'S KIND OF PART OF OUR
GENERAL PRINCIPLE OF REMOVING
BARRIERS TO ELIGIBILITY AND
ACCESS TO CAL GRANT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE'VE BEEN EMPHASIZING FOR
RECENT YEARS IN THAT -- THE
LEGISLATION THAT YOU MISTER
DINNER CO AUTHORING EMPHASIZES
AS WELL.
FINALLY ON THIS PAGE THERE'S ONE
MORE ITEM AFTER THE FINALLY ON
PAGE THREE AND LEADING ON THE
PAGE.
FOR SOME OF A LOOK AT THE HIGH
SCHOOL ENTITLEMENT WINDOW SO AS
YOU MENTIONED EARLIER CHAIR THAT
ENTITLEMENT VERSUS COMPETITIVE
DISCUSSION.
PRIMARILY HINGES ON HOW LONG IT
HAS BEEN SINCE A STUDENT
GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL ONE OF THE
MOST PROGRESSIVE STEPS THIS
LEGISLATURE TOOK IN.
TWO THOUSAND IN AN ACTING --
SENATE BILL SIXTEEN FORTY FOUR
THE VASCONCELOS PARTICULAR TEASE
CAL GRANT ACT WAS IN SAYING THAT
ANY STUDENT WHO'S WITHIN ONE
YEAR OF GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL IS
ENTITLED TO A CALDERON AWARD.
IF THEY APPLY ON TIME MEET THE
GPA AND INCOME REQUIREMENTS
HOWEVER AGAIN AS WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING FOR MORE STUDENTS ARE.
FOR YOU KNOW OFTEN PERFECTLY
VALID REASONS TAKING A LITTLE
LONGER TO ATTEND COLLEGE OR
ATTENDING A LITTLE BIT LATER
INTO THEIR TWENTIES OR LATER.
AND SO WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
AND FOR THOSE STUDENTS THERE
PRIMARILY SERVE BY THE
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS
SINCE -- THAT IS -- THAT'S THE
STATE'S PRIMARY VEHICLE FOR
SERVING THE QUOTE UNQUOTE ADULT
LEARNER POPULATION SO WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT IT
WOULD MAKE SENSE TO SORT OF ADD
SOME TIME TO THAT WINDOW SAY.
CAL GRANT TO ENTITLEMENT FOR TWO
YEARS AFTER HIGH SCHOOL THREE
YEARS AFTER HIGH SCHOOL FIVE
YEARS OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL AND
THIS ACTUALLY WILL WOULD CUT
INTO THE COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM AND IF YOU'RE A REDUCE
THAT SORT OF PRESSURE.
AND DEMAND ON THE COMPETITIVE
CAL GRANT PROGRAM BY PROVIDING
MORE TIME FOR THE STUDENTS TO
GET ENTITLEMENT CALDERON. TO ADD
ONE YEAR TO MAKE IT COVER AN
ANTI ONE FOR TWO YEARS AT A HIGH
SCHOOL WOULD COST APPROXIMATELY
THIRTY SIX MILLION. TO MAKE IT
THREE YEARS GOES UP
SIGNIFICANTLY NINETY SEVEN
MILLION AND TO MAKE IT IN TIME
FOR FIVE YEARS OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL YOU SEE ON PAGE. FOUR TWO
HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN MILLION BUT
AGAIN THAT WOULD IN TURN REDUCE
SOME OF THE PRESSURE IN DEMAND
ON THE COMPETITIVE CAL THAT
PROGRAM BECAUSE THOSE OF THE
STUDENTS THAT ARE PRIMARILY
SURVEY THAT PROGRAM NOW.
SO IT'S KIND OF AN EITHER OR
VERSUS INCREASING THE NUMBER
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANTS AVAILABLE
OR INCREASING THE ENTITLEMENT
WINDOW OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL --
FINALLY IN THIS DOCUMENT WE
TALKED ABOUT -- PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL CAL GRANT ELIGIBILITY
FOR STUDENTS TAKING SUMMER
COURSE WORK A. K. A. SUMMER CAL
GRANT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS
IN ASSEMBLY BILL.
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN THAT HAS BEEN
DISCUSSED FOR MANY YEARS NOW
THAT -- OUR PARTNERS AND FRIENDS
AT THE STUDENT ASSOCIATIONS ARE
PROMOTING HEAVILY THIS YEAR
ESSENTIALLY RIGHT NOW STUDENT
WHO ATTENDS COLLEGE AND TAKE
SUMMER COURSEWORK THEY CAN USE
THEIR CAL GRANT FOR THE SUMMER
COURSES.
BUT IT DRAWS DOWN FROM THE
LIFETIME ELIGIBILITY SO YOU HAVE
A SITUATION WHERE STUDENTS ARE
TAKING THOSE SUMMER COURSES
GETTING CAL GRANT TO SUPPORT
THEM BECAUSE THEY WANT TO TRAIN
GRADUATE WITHIN FOUR YEARS.
BUT THEN THEY MIGHT GET TO THAT
FINAL SEMESTER THEIR SENIOR YEAR
AND OOPS YOU'RE OUT OF CAL GRANT.
YOU HAVE TO FIND A WAY TO COVER
WITH LOANS WORKING EXTRA WHICH
CAN ACTUALLY PROLONG SORT OF
HAVE THE PERVERSE EFFECT OF
PROLONGING THE AMOUNT OF TIME
THAT IT TAKES THEM TO GRADUATE.
SO -- OUR COMMISSION IS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS AND WE'RE
WORKING WITH PARTNERS -- IN THE
STERN ASSOCIATIONS AND WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MEDINA MCCARTY
AND THEY'RE LEGISLATION TO
PROVIDE WHAT WE CALL BONUS
ELIGIBILITY FOR STUDENTS TAKING
SUMMER COURSE WORK SO THAT.
THEY CAN TAKE A CERTAIN NUMBER
SUMMER TERMS USE A CAL GRANT GET
THAT FINANCIAL AID HOPEFULLY
GRADUATE ON TIME AND NOT BE
PENALIZED SORT OF ON THE BACK
AND FOR THAT.
THAT'S IT FOR THIS -- DOCUMENTS
HERE IN MEMBERS THAT SORT OF
SCORES SOME OF THESE PROPOSALS --
CALDERON AUGMENTATIONS THAT WE
HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING THERE ARE
SEVERAL OTHERS SOME SORT OF NO
COST -- LOW LIFT CAL GRANT
REFORMS THAT WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING SUCH AS INCLUDING OUR
AB FIVE FORTY STUDENTS AND
DREAMERS IN THE COMPETITIVE CAL
GRANT PROGRAM WHICH IS NOT IN
AND OF ITSELF CARRY.
A COST BECAUSE THE NUMBER OF
COMPETITIVE AWARDS CAPPED --
THAT WERE HAPPY TO DISCUSS AND
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU ON
OKAY.
THANK YOU FOR PROVIDING US WITH
THE ROAD MAP SO I JUST HAVE THE
PLAN THAT WE'RE GOING TO A TOP
TRACK HERE.
IN MY LITTLE NOTES SO.
I CAN'T TELL YOU JUST YET DOW
BUT HOPEFULLY THAT -- LEDGER THE
MAY REVISE GONNA LOOK ATTRACTIVE
WILL BE ABLE. TO TO TO PICK AND
CHOOSE FROM THE MENU HERE. TO
REALLY STEP IT UP WITH OUR
FINANCIALLY THE ONE THING THAT
WE DIDN'T HAVE ON HERE.
THE WHICH IS IMPORTANT TO US IS
THESE -- ADAM AWARDS.
AND SO DO YOU HAVE ANY.
ANALYSIS AS FAR AS HOW MUCH THAT
IS FOR THE CAL GRANT MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP FOR THAT. FOR
THE NON TUITIONS CERTAINLY AND
AND WE HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING THAT
WITH COMMITTEE STAFF AS WELL
THAT WAS A LITTLE BIT HARDER TO
SCORE -- BECAUSE IT SORT OF
DEPENDS ON THE I THINK WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT IS THE
NOTION THAT WE WOULD CONSOLIDATE
CAL GRANT AB AND C. A MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP HAVE ONE CAL
GRANT TO SOME.
AND HAVE THE WORDS KIND OF
TAPERED DOWN AS THE STUDENTS
INCOME GOES UP -- IF I RECALL
CORRECTLY AND HELP YOU SOME
SUPPORT FOR NON TUITION EXPENSES
THE JUST SORT OF GOES SCALED
DOWN AS AS THE STUDENT INCOME OR
NEED YOU KNOW YEAH RACES -- NOPE
WOULD WANT TO TAPER DOWN THAT
SAID POLICY DISCUSSION BUT HER
POTENTIALLY TAPER AT TAPERED UP.
TO COVER THE THAT THE NON
TUITION COSTS SPECIALLY FOR THE
LOWEST INCOME.
SURE YEAH AND WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THAT I THINK IT JUST
DEPENDS ON THE MODEL THAT'S USED
BUT WE CAN CONTINUE WORKING WITH
ALL OF THE ROUTE.
THAT WIND THE THE BALLPARK -- SO
ARE YOU ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT
HAVING LIKE -- LIKE SETTING THAT
NON TUITION AWARD WILL BE CALLED
THE CAL GRANT BE AXIS WARD AT
ABOUT LIKE LIKE UP YEARS AGO WE
DID THERE ARE.
DEBT FREE COLLEGE SURE GRANTS
WHERE'D.
I THINK IT WAS ROUGHLY. FIFTY
THREE THOUSAND AND EIGHT
THOUSAND THE AVERAGE CAL GRANT
RECIPIENT WILL RECEIVE.
THIS AMOUNT IN ADDITION EVERY
YEAR -- FOR FOR NON TUITION
COSTS.
SO TO DO THAT SORT OF SYSTEM
WHICH I THINK REPRESENTS A
PRETTY COMPREHENSIVE OVERHAUL.
WOULD BE ROUGHLY IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF ONE AND A HALF
TO TWO BILLION AND THAT'S A
PRETTY COMPREHENSIVE OVERHAUL
THAT INVOLVES IF I'M IF I'M
UNDERSTANDING CORRECTLY THE SORT
OF MODEL WHERE THERE'S A
EXPECTED STUDENT CONTRIBUTION%
FROM WORKER LOANS.
AND THEN FEDERAL INSTITUTIONAL
STATED WILL COMBINE TO MEET THE
REMAINDER OF THE COST OF
ATTENDANCE AND FOR THOSE LOW
INCOME HIGHER NEED STUDENTS THAT
GRANT WILL BE.
A LITTLE HIGHER TO ENSURE THAT
THEIR COST OF ATTENDANCE IS
COVERED I'VE SEEN VARIOUS MODELS
OF THAT IN THE ONE AND A HALF TO
TWO BILLION DOLLAR RANGE.
YES THAT'S OBVIOUSLY THE LARGEST --
DOLLAR SIGN ON THESE PROPOSAL SO
IF YOU ADD UP.
ALL THESE PROPOSALS AND AND
LET'S SAY -- THE MOST COST
EFFICIENT.
CHOICE ON HERE AND SOME OF THE
ONES WE HAVE MULTIPLE OPTIONS IS
WHO IS WITHIN THE LOW COUPLE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR RANGE
SACKED.
THAT'S THE ESSENTIALLY VIABLE
FEET.
IF YOU DID A A MULTI YEAR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT.
SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I THINK
WE WILL BE EVALUATING I GUESS I
I KNOW SOME MY COLLEAGUES HE HAS
SOME QUESTIONS HERE.
TO ABOUT ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT
I I'VE ALWAYS GRAPPLE WITH.
AND IT'S IT'S KIND OF BACK TO
THE FIRST ISSUE.
IS IF YOU IF YOU HAVE A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF STUDENTS WHO ARE WHO
ARE IN.
THEY HAVE A ARE YOU BETTER OFF
GIVING THEM BETTER EIGHT ARE
HELPING THE STUDENTS WHO DIDN'T
GET A IN THE FIRST PLACE.
IN OTHER WORDS WE HAVE WE HAVE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE A CAL GRANT.
AWARD MAYBE IT SAID INSUFFICIENT
ARE INFERIOR WORD THE ACCESS
GRANTS AREN'T LOW ENOUGH WE
DON'T COVER.
TUITION THE FIRST YEAR BUT
THEY'RE GETTING AID AND SO MANY
STUDENTS ARE GETTING A AT ALL.
THE COMPETITIVE -- STE THE US
THE STUDENTS FOR PARTICULAR
PEOPLE IN THAT DONNA HOLD SO FOR
SO.
WHO WHAT WHAT'S THE BIGGEST?
BANG FOR YOUR BUCK IF YOU COULD --
OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO DO BOTH AND
I ASKED.
LAST YEAR WITH THE TO THIS
QUESTION AND SHE ONE ANSWER SO
IF YOU HAD.
YOU KNOW A COUPLE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS HE IS CHOOSE ONE
OF THE OTHER.
WHAT WOULD YOU DO?
IT'S GOING TO SOUND LIKE I'M
HUNTING BUT WITH THE NEW
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR STARTING
TOMORROW THIS THIS IS EITHER
MIGHT.
MY CHANCE OR I SHOULD KEEP MY
MOUTH SHUT BUT I WOULD SAY IT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY HAVE TO BE
AN EITHER OR I WOULD SAY THAT --
HE IN DISCUSSIONS WE'VE HAD WITH
STAKEHOLDERS THIS DOESN'T
REPRESENT LIKE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION OF COMMISSIONS TAKEN
BUT DISCUSSIONS OF HAVE A
STAKEHOLDERS I THINK THAT
INTERNALLY WE HAVE INCREASINGLY
COME TO THE CONCLUSION THAT.
IT DOES NEED TO BE A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT WE WE DO NEED TO
PROVIDE BOTH MORE AID. FOR
STUDENTS WHO ARE ALREADY IN THE
SYSTEM BUT WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE ARE A WHOLE LOT OF
STUDENTS THAT AREN'T EVEN IN
DUTIES ELIGIBILITY.
THERE IS WE CREATED AND ON THAT
LATTER POINT TO THE ELIGIBILITY
BEARERS I THINK THAT'S WHERE YOU
SEE -- YOU SEE A LOT OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS WHO
ARE SERVED AS WELL BY THE
CURRENT CAL GRANT ELIGIBILITY
CRITERIA.
AND THAT TO A LARGE EXTENT IS
WHY -- I THINK WE'D LIKE TO SEE.
YOU KNOW WHETHER IT'S FIFTY
FIFTY OR OR CLOSE TO FIFTY FIFTY
BUT SOME SOMETHING CLOSE EQUAL
ATTENTION PAID TO OF BOTH THE
BREATH VERSUS DEPTH THE IDEA
THAT.
WE'D LIKE TO SEE MORE STUDENTS
GET INTO THE FINANCIAL AID
SYSTEM AND GET CAL GRANT TO
BEGIN WITH BUT WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO SEE THOSE THAT ARE GETTING IT.
PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT HAVE THE
HIGHEST NEEDHAM HEIGHTS COST GET
MORE EIGHT YEAH BUT THE FLIP
SIDE OF THAT IF YOU TRY TO BE A
LITTLE BIT. TO A LOT OF PEOPLE
YOU'RE NOTHING TO NOBODY.
AND SO AND THERE'S THERE ARE
SOME PIECES THAT YOU COULD JUST
DO THE WHOLE THING.
LIKE THAT THAT THAT THAT.
DOES NOT HOLD THE STUDENTS TO
HAVE INCOMES BETWEEN FIFTY AND A
HUNDRED GRAND THAT HE PAYS JUST
BELOW THREE POINT OUT. TO TO
CLOSE THAT HOLE IS WHAT. FORTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS.
AND THEN THAT THE SUMMER SCHOOL --
PIECES LESS THAN TEN MILLION
DOLLARS AND WE'RE NOT SURE IF
THAT ACCURATE NUMBERS ON THAT.
AND SO -- YOU KNOW TO INCREASING
THE WINDOW FOR TWO YEARS FOR
ENTITLEMENTS THIRTY SIX MILLION
CELL.
WOULD YOU WOULD YOU ADVISE DOING
SOME OF THOSE ALL OF THEM AS
OPPOSED TO SPREADING THEM OUT IF
WE IF WE DIDN'T HAVE THE AMOUNT
TO DO A ALL TO GO ALL THE WAY.
IN IN THAT.
OUT OF THE GATE.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE.
I THINK THAT'S A THAT THAT WOULD
BE A FAIR ASSESSMENT YEAH THAT
WE HAVE THERE THERE ARE
CERTAINLY SOME STEPS THAT -- IN
THE INTEREST OF PURSUING A
SYSTEMIC BEYOND OVERHAUL OF A
FINANCIALLY SYSTEM.
THAT WE WOULD PROBABLY RECOMMEND
BE DONE ALL AS ONE BUT THAT
AGAIN IS A POLICY CALL AND AS I
THINK WE DISCUSSED IN FEBRUARY
THE FINANCIAL AID HEARING. TO A
LARGE EXTENT IT ALSO DEPENDS ON
THE ON THE GOAL THE ON THE
LEGISLATURE'S GOALS AND IF THE
GOAL IS.
TO REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF DEBT
YOUNG STUDENTS GRADUATE WITH IS
IF THE GOAL IS TO GET MORE
STUDENTS YOU KNOW TO BE ABLE TO
AFFORD IN A TOWN CALLED TO BEGIN
WITH -- I THINK THAT -- OUR
RECOMMENDATION WOULD BE TO ONLY
START SOME DISCUSSION OF WHAT
THOSE GOALS ARE AND THEN SORT OF
FIGURE OUT WHICH PIECES OF THE
FINANCIALLY REFORM WOULD BE MOST
EFFECTIVE IN MEETING THOSE.
WELL I I THINK OUR GOAL IS TWO
FOLD AS YOU SAID EARLIER WE HAVE
THIS CAL GRANT PROGRAM WHICH IS
ONE OF THE AND THESE OF THE
NATION AS FAR AS OUR OUR EFFORTS
IS NEARLY TWO BILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR.
WE SPENT ON ON FINANCIAL AID BUT
WE NEED TO REALIZE TWO THINGS
THAT.
WON THE AWARDS JUST AREN'T WHAT
THEY THEY USED TO BE WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE TOTAL COST OF
INSTRUCTION THAT.
WE LOOK AT BOOKS AND HOUSING AND
FOOD AND TRANSPORTATION.
THE TUITION IS JUST A PIECE OF
THE PUZZLE YESTERDAY I WAS AT
THAT AT THE CSU AND WORK TWO
THIRDS OF THE STUDENTS THERE.
GET SOME TYPE OF FINANCIAL AID
TO PAY FOR TUITION BUT THEY'RE
STILL STRAPPED THEY HAD THE FOOD
PANTRIES WHICH IS UNBELIEVABLE
WE HAVE FOOD PANTRIES ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES NOW YEAH. ONE IN TEN
STUDENTS AT CS YOUR HOMELESS
WERE DEBATING A BILL TO ALLOW
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS TO
SLEEP IN PARKING LOTS.
MANY.
THAT THAT'S UNBELIEVABLE TO GO
BACK TEN OR FIFTEEN YEARS AND SO.
I THINK WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE
FINANCIAL AID MODEL TO COVER
THESE NON TUITION COSTS SO.
STREAMY PROPOLIS ON THAT ON THE
ADD ON A WORDS TO TO GO TO THE
BENCH WE GET TO A PATH WHERE YOU
CAN GRADUATE DEBT FREE.
NOT FREE CALLS BUT DEBT FREE.
BUT THE BUT THE OTHER THIS ISSUE
TOO IS THAT THERE'S TOO MANY
STUDENTS WHO JUST.
MISSED OUT AND WE'VE BEEN
TWEAKING THIS GREAT CAL GRANT
PROGRAM FOR DECADES BUT EVERY
TWEAK IS.
CARVING PEOPLE OUT AND AS AS
THAT MR DONNA SAID EARLIER YOU
HAVE TO HAVE THAT.
AT PHD IN FINANCIAL AID TO
UNDERSTAND THIS WHEN WHEN WE
LITERALLY.
DRAFTED THE BILL. TO REFORM THE
CAL GRANT PROPOSAL IT TOOK
PLEDGE COUNCIL MULTIPLE LAYERS
IN A MONTH. TO FIGURE IT OUT
FINALLY SAID YOU KNOW WHAT THIS
IS SCRAP IT AND START FROM
SCRATCH BECAUSE WE HAVE SO MANY.
CARVE OUTS AND ADD ONS IN THIS
PERSON BUT NOT THAT PERSON THAT.
AND SO IT JUST IT -- I KNOW
WE'VE TRIED OVER THE YEARS TO
EXPAND FINANCIALLY BUT WE MADE
ONE MORE COMPLICATED INTO WERE
STILL.
A SQUEEZING OUT TOO MANY PEOPLE
WHO ARE WHO ARE ELIGIBLE AND
NEEDY SO -- THIS IS CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT.
WE'RE GONNA ATTEMPTED TO STEP UP
IN OUR FINAL BUDGET AND AND
ATTEMPT TO IMPLEMENT OVER A
NUMBER YEARS WE THINK YOU KNOW
EVEN OUT.
BY JUST KIND OF TIGHT WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO START TO
START THIS YEAR SO SO WITH THAT
LET ME I TURNED OVER A FIRST TO
MISTER O'DONNELL.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AGAIN I THINK YOU BRING UP THE
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP I HOPE
WE DON'T TAPER DOWN ANYTHING --
A FOR ANY LEVEL -- IN PARTICULAR --
TALK ABOUT THE THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP THING THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE I AGAIN I I I ASSURE YOU
THE FRUSTRATION ON HEARING.
OUT IN THE COMMUNITY WITH REGARD.
TO TO TO THE NEEDS OF THE MIDDLE
CLASS WHICH I DON'T THINK THE
STATE PAYS ENOUGH ATTENTION.
TO PRETTY EITHER WAY -- I JUST
WANNA GET A LITTLE PRACTICAL --
MY MY MY MY BACKGROUND AS
CLASSROOM TEACHER I WOULD
ACTUALLY HAVE STUDENTS.
I SIGNED UP FOR THE FAST FOR IN
MY CLASSROOM -- I WAS SOCIAL
STUDIES IT WASN'T MY PURVIEW BUT
I THE COUNCIL WOULD COME IN AND
THEY DO HAVE THAT THE STUDENTS --
AND IT WAS AN INTERESTING
EXPERIENCE -- BUT SO SO AFTER
STUDENTS SENSE OF HER FAST FOLK
WHO.
WHOSE RESPONSIBILITY IS IT. TO
EDUCATE -- ANY PARTICULAR
STUDENT -- ABOUT WHAT FINANCIAL%
AID MIGHT BE AVAILABLE WOULD
THAT BE THE DUTY OF THE SCHOOL
COUNSELOR WOULD BE THE FAMILY
WOULD BE THE STUDENT WOULD BE A
POTENTIALCOLLEGE.
IS IS THERE ANY MANDATED PLACE
OR IS IT JUST KIND OF A RIGHT
IT'S IT'S KIND OF A A NETWORK --
OF OF FOLKS SO -- I WOULD SAY
THAT WHEN THE STUDENT IS A WHEN
THEY'RE STILL IN HIGH SCHOOL IT
WOULD BE IT WOULD PRIMARILY BE
SOMEBODY THE HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL
HAS -- COUNSELOR THAT'S ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT IN ONE OF THE
PREVIOUS ISSUES WE DISCUSSED
HERE THAT WE'RE SEEKING MORE
STAFFING FOR THE COMMISSION IS
THAT WE DO WORKSHOPS ABOUT FORTY
WORKSHOPS A YEAR RETRAIN HIGH
SCHOOL COUNSELORS.
AND BOB BECAUSE THAT'S HOW
COMPLEX OUR FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM
IS THAT WE O OUT WE TRAIN HIGH
SCHOOL COUNCILS IT'S ALL THE
WORKSHOPS WHERE WE GO THROUGH
EVERY LINE OF THE FAST SO WITH
THEM TO GO THROUGH ALL THE
CHANGES THAT HAVE BEEN MADE --
TO MAKE SURE THEY UNDERSTAND
HERE CAN'T CAN'T COMMUNICATE IT
TO STUDENTS AND FAMILIES.
SO YEAH THE HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL
PROBABLY PRIMARILY THE COUNSELOR --
CERTAINLY THE STUDENT A
COMMISSION WE PUT ON OVER
THOUSAND CASH FOR COLLEGE
WORKSHOPS HERE WHICH ARE FREE
ALL THROUGHOUT THE STATE EVERY
REGION OF THE STATE -- WHERE WE
DO OUR BEST TO EDUCATE STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES ABOUT FINANCIAL AID --
AS WELL AS THROUGH OUR CAL SO
PROGRAM TO UP IF I TARGETED
SERVICES -- TO LOW INCOME
STUDENTS -- AND SORT OF FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS AND THEN.
WHEN THE STUDENT GETS TO THE
COLLEGE CAMPUS THERE'S A
FINANCIAL AID OFFICE ON THE
CAMPUS -- WHICH IS USUALLY THEIR
FIRST DIRECT POINT OF CONTACT WE
HAVE A CALL CENTER TO STUDENT A
COMMISSION BUT PRIMARILY ONCE
THEY'RE ON THE CAMPUS IT'S THEIR
FINANCIAL AID OFFICER ON THE
CAMPUS WHO UNDERSTANDS THE
SYSTEM -- OF THE BEST SO IT IS
SORT OF A NETWORK OF DIFFERENT
AND IT.
IT'S ALL REFLECTED OFF OF THE
FASTER.
YEAH THE FASTER THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM ACT APPLICATION IF THEY'RE
AN ELIGIBLE AB FIVE FORTY
STUDENTS SO WHEN THEY DON'T DO
HAS FOR THAT'S WHAT THAT'S WHAT
THEY FILL OUT BECAUSE OF THEIR
MAYBE THE DOCTOR CORRECTION THAT
YET YES -- IT'S SO SO IS THERE
IS THERE ONE OF SO THAT IT'S A
MALE THEM IT'S DONE IT'S EMAIL
TO THEM HOW DO THEY GET THE
INFORMATION ABOUT.
WHAT'S AVAILABLE TO THEM -- IT
JUST SORT OF DEPENDS ON THEIR
THERE'S NO UNIFORM SYSTEM I
THINK FOR NOTIFYING OR DOING
OUTREACH TO STUDENTS THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE CONSTANTLY
LOOKING AT ITS WASTE OF SORT OF
BETTER IMPROVE THAT
COMMUNICATION.
BUT REALLY -- IT IT USUALLY I
BELIEVE MY EXPERIENCE WILL
HAPPEN AT THE HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL
FIRST -- THAT THEY FIND THAT OUT
AND THEY CAN THE FAST IS
AVAILABLE IT'S FREE IT'S
AVAILABLE ONLINE -- LIKE I SAID
THEY CAN COME TO ONE OF OUR CASH
FOR COLLEGE WORKSHOPS BUT I
DON'T THINK I THINK IT JUST SORT
OF DEPENDS ON THE RESOURCES THE
SCHOOL HAS THE THE AREA THE
STATE THERE AND AT CENTER AS TO
WHEN AND WHERE THEY GET THE
INFORMATION.
SO IS THERE -- IS THERE LIKE A
WEBSITE THEY WOULD GO TO THE
TYPE AND SOMETIME A NUMBER AND
THEY TAKE.
PAPA BAM THIS IS WHAT IS
AVAILABLE TO ME BASED ON MY FAST
FOR INFORMATION YES -- MOSTLY
YES YES SIR THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION WE HAVE HISTORICALLY
HOUSED -- AND THAT PRICE
CALCULATOR IS THE OFFICIAL TERM
THE USE IN FINANCIAL AID --
STATEWIDE -- CURRENTLY WORKING
ON REVAMPING THAT BUT EVERY
COLLEGE ALSO HAS A NET PRICE
CALCULATOR AVAILABLE ON THEIR
WEBSITE THAT SORT OF DOES A VERY
ROUGH ESTIMATE IF YOU TYPE IN
YOUR SITUATION YOUR FAMILY
HOUSEHOLD SIZE.
INCOME THINGS LIKE THAT AND AN
ATTEMPT TO GET KIND OF A ROUGH
BREAKDOWN OF THE TYPICAL COST AS
WELL AS THE FINANCIALLY THAT
WOULD LIKELY BE AVAILABLE TO A
TYPICAL STUDENT THAT SITUATION.
MITCHELL WORKING ON A STATE WIDE
ONE I THINK WE'D LIKE TO SEE
ULTIMATELY THAT WOULD ANY
STUDENT IN CALIFORNIA GO TO OUR
WEBSITE AND GET THAT INFORMATION
FROM US I THINK THAT'S A PART I
THINK THAT'S THAT'S DEFINITELY
POSITIVE AS AS AS MISTER CHAIR
TO CONTEMPLATE SOME OF THE
CHANGES.
I HOPE THAT'S PART OF THE
DISCUSSION AND ACTUALLY THERE'S
OTHER CHANGES THAT THAT THE
COMMISSION HAS OR YOU HAVE.
STUDENTS CERTAINLY HELP THOSE
WILL BE INCLUDED IN ANY
POTENTIAL EFFORT TO TO STREAM
LIKE THIS AND MAKE IT MORE.
UNDERSTANDABLE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
MR MEDINA.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE THIS
MORNING -- IMPORTANT TOPIC -- TO
A MISTER DONALD'S.
HOW STUDENTS FIND OUT I I
REMEMBER -- YEAR TWO YEARS AGO --
A. B. FIVE FORTY STUDENTS WERE
NOT -- APPLYING AS MUCH FILLING
OUT -- THE FINANCIAL AID AND I
KNOW THAT THAT.
LET YOU KNOW CAUCUS TOOK PART IN
THE OUT REACH MEDIA OUT READ SO
I THINK THOSE KIND OF THINGS ARE.
ARE ARE VERY GOOD -- TO THE TO
THE QUESTION OF WHEN WAS THE
LAST TIME IF YOU COULD TELL ME.
WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME THAT WE
TRY TO OVERALL?
OVERHAUL THE ENTIRE -- STUDENT --
EIGHT PACKAGES SURE -- I BELIEVE
I WOULD SAY THAT YOU KNOW IT
THERE THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP WAS ADDED.
SEVERAL YEARS AGO -- THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT WAS ENACTED
IN TWENTY ELEVEN BUT I WOULD SAY
THAT THE LAST SORT OF MAJOR
SYSTEMIC OVER HALLWAYS IN TWO
THOUSAND THE PASSAGE OF THE
VASCONCELOS -- ORTIZ BUT YOU CAN
CAL GRANT US SENATE BILL SIXTEEN
FORTY FOUR WHICH CREATED THE
ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM HAS GONE
TRANSFER ENTITLEMENT PROGRAMS TO
IT'S BEEN ALMOST TWENTY YEARS
CORRECT.
AND THEN TO SOMETHING THAT --
THE CHAIR MCCARTY ALLUDED TO THE
THE COMPLEXITY OF IT.
WHICH I I I HEAR A LOT -- ALSO A
HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER BEEN TO SOME
OF THOSE CASH. FOR CLLEGE --
WORKSHOPS WITCHER ARE ARE VERY
GOOD.
DO DO WE ENVISION IN THIS -- AND
AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO PROPOSE
A SYSTEM THAT THAT GETS AWAY
WITH SOME OF ALL THE DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES AND TRIES -- TO MAKE
IT MORE USER FRIENDLY AND AND
PERHAPS SIMPLER.
ABSOLUTELY I THINK -- FROM THE
COMMISSION AND WORKING WITH --
THAT EXCELLENT STAFF YOUR POLICY
COMMITTEE ON OFFICE STAFF IN THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE STAFF -- WE
HAVE CONSISTENTLY BEEN SPEAKING
ABOUT IN SUPPORTING THE IDEA OF
A STREAMLINED SORT OF ONE CAL
GRANT SYSTEM -- FOR LACK OF A
BETTER TERMINOLOGY THERE WILL
STILL BE COMPLEXITIES FINANCIAL
AID.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO GET AWAY FROM
SOME OF THE COMPLEXITIES BECAUSE
THERE'S MULTIPLE LAYERS FEDERAL
LATER STATED THERE'S A PROVIDED
BY THE INSTITUTION.
SO BUT AS A COLLEAGUE OF MINE
LIKES TO SAY.
IN OUR IDEAL WORLD WE WOULD PUT
AS MUCH OF THAT COMPLEXITY
BEHIND THE CURTAIN AS POSSIBLE
SO THE STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
DON'T NEED.
TO SEE THIS DETAILED BREAKDOWN
OF THE DIFFERENT COMPONENTS OF
CAL GRANT APPELLATE RAN IN
INCOME AN EXPECTED FAMILY
CONTRIBUTION THAT THE THAT FROM
THE STUDENT PERSPECTIVE -- THEY
JUST NEED TO PROVIDE A SMALL
AMOUNT OF INFORMATION AND THEY
WOULD IDEALLY IMMEDIATELY KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE ELIGIBLE FOR AND
HOW TO GET IT SO YOU YOU
WOULDN'T BE APPLYING.
FOR YOU KNOW A. BE COMPETITIVE
WE'RE TRYING TO WORK WITH WE
WOULD IDEALLY LIKE TO STUDENT TO
NOT EVEN HAVE TO KNOW THOSE
TERMS -- IF AT ALL POSSIBLE TO
JUST KNOW THAT THERE'S A CAL
GRANT PROGRAM OUT THERE THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- BELIEVES
IN THEM AND WANTS TO INVEST IN
THEIR SUCCESS -- IN HIGHER
EDUCATION.
SO HOPEFULLY AT THE END OF THE
DAY IT WILL BE MORE USER
FRIENDLY AND AN ABSOLUTE MORE.
SIMPLIFY ABSOLUTELY AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE LEGISLATION
ESTIMABLE THIRTEEN FOURTEEN AND
VISIONS.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALREADY THIS IS SOMETHING WE'RE
GOING -- TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
AND AND THAT WE THINK BRING BACK
A PROPOSAL TO VOTE ON DURING THE
MAY REVISE BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY --
YEAH THANKS FOR YOUR WORK IN AND
STEPPING UP I KNOW THAT STUDENTS
ACROSS -- CALIFORNIA ASKING US
TO FIX FINANCIAL AID AND THIS IS
THIS IS -- A BIG PIECE OF THE
PUZZLE THAT WE'RE GONNA.
LOOK AT DOING THIS YEAR THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
A WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN --
WITH THAT WE WILL PROCEED NOW TO
THE ITEMS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LIBRARY.
PLEASE COME UP.
LIBRARY TEAM
.
OKAY ISSUE NUMBER.
ONE THAT CHAIRMAN CHRIS FERGUSON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LIBRARY SERVES A CRITICAL ROLE
IN STATE GOVERNMENT BY SERVING
AT THE CENTRAL REFERENCE AND
RESEARCH LIBRARY. FOR THE
GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATURE
ADDITIONALLY THE STATE LIBRARY
PROVIDES CRITICAL ASSISTANCE AND
DISTRIBUTES FEDERAL FUNDS TO THE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FOUR LIBRARY
JURISDICTIONS IN OVER TWELVE
HUNDRED LIBRARIES ACROSS THE
STATE -- OVERALL THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET REPRESENTS OVER A THIRTY
MILLION DOLLAR -- BUDGET GENERAL
FUND BUDGET FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LIBRARY AND THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY FISCAL YEAR --
FOR THE FIRST ISSUE -- THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES ONE
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME TO
SUPPORT THE LUNCH AT THE LIBRARY
PROGRAM -- THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LIBRARY -- IT
TO LOCAL LIBRARY WHICH IS A
GRANT PROGRAM FOR LOCAL LIBRARY
JURISDICTIONS -- THE GOAL IS TO
OF THE THE INVESTMENT IS TO
ASSIST LOCAL LIBRARIES AND
SETTING UP -- MEAL LUNCH
PROGRAMS TO DRAW DOWN -- FEDERAL
FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE ACTUAL
LUNCH.
OKAY HELLO.
CHOOSING CONCENTRA SALLY -- FOR
SOME CONTEXT ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL --
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT RUNS A
SUMMER MEAL PROGRAM -- TO
PROVIDE FREE MEALS TO STUDENTS
DURING THE SUMMER WHEN THEY'RE
NOT IN REAL ATTENDING SCHOOL.
THIS ONE TO THE LIBRARY PROGRAM.
THE AIM OF IT IS TO INCREASE
LIBRARY PARTICIPATION INTO THAT
FEDERAL PROGRAM.
THE FEDERAL FUNDS SUPPORT THE
MEALS DIRECTLY AND SO WHAT THE
STATE FUNDS WOULD DO IN THIS
CASE WOULD.
PROVIDE A SUPPORT THAT ASSIST
LIBRARIES AND PARTICIPATING IN
THAT FEDERAL PROGRAM SO PORTION
OF FUNDING WOULD BE FOR OUT
REACH TO GET MORE LIBRARIES TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM.
ANOTHER PORTION OF FUNDING WOULD
PROVIDE GRANTS THAT EITHER HELP
LIBRARIES WITH THE START UP
COSTS TO DEVELOP THE SIGHTS.
IT WOULD ALSO PROVIDE FUNDING
FOR WHICH YOU COULD THINK OF A
WRAPAROUND SERVICES ARE READING
PROGRAMS AND OTHER IN SUMMER AND
MUCH MORE PROGRAMS THAT STUDENTS --
WHAT COULD PARTICIPATE IN AS
THEIR -- ACCESSING A FREE MEAL.
AND PROPOSED AND DEVELOPING THIS
PROPOSAL WE THINK THE GOVERNOR
HAS REYES A SAILING ISSUE FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER
WHICH IS.
OF FOOD INSECURITY AMONG
CHILDREN DURING THE SUMMER --
SOME ESTIMATES SUGGEST THAT --
ABOUT 19% OF CALIFORNIA CHILDREN
OR FOOD AND SECURE.
THERE ISN'T DATA ON THE
SEASONALITY OF THAT BUT IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT THAT INSECURITY
INCREASES DURING THE SUMMER WHEN
STUDENTS AREN'T ENROLLED IN
SCHOOL.
AND THAT RATE -- FLUCTUATES
SOMEWHAT -- IT'S THE TIRE INLAND --
TO TEND TO BE HIGHER IN IN ONE
COUNTIES MORE ALONG THE COAST
BUT THERE IS SOME VARIABILITY
THERE ACROSS THE STATE.
WE ALSO THINK THE GOVERNOR'S
APPROACH OF OF TRYING TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE BY -- DRAWING DOWN
MORE FEDERAL FUNDS IS REASONABLE --
OUR CONCERN HERE IS THAT -- BY
FOCUSING JUST ON LIBRARY
PARTICIPATION.
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S TAKING A SOMEWHAT
NARROW APPROACH.
OF THE FEDERAL MEAL PROGRAM
LIBRARIES ARE ARE ONE IT SORT OF
ENTITIES THAT CAN PARTICIPATE IN
IT SCHOOLS CAN ALSO SERVICE
SITES OTHER NON PROFITS AND
LOCAL INDIES CAM CONSERVA SITES.
AND PRESUMABLY -- COMMUNITIES
VERY IN TERMS OF WHICH OF THESE
SITES ARE THE BEST FOR SITES TO
DELIVER MEALS TO TWO CHILDREN.
GIVEN THIS CONCERN WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE DIRECT THE STATE
LIBRARY TO COORDINATE -- WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
DEVELOP A A MORE COMPREHENSIVE
PLAN I'M NOT COMPREHENSIVE PLAN
WOULDN'T INCLUDE THINGS LIKE --
INVITING MORE SITES TO
PARTICIPATE NOT JUST LIBRARIES --
WOULD CONSIDER COMPREHENSIVE SET
OF PLANS -- TO ENCOURAGE MORE
CHILDREN TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
MAIL PROGRAM THAT COULD INCLUDE
MORE SITES BUT ALSO POTENTIALLY
OTHER.
OPTIONS LIKE IMPROVING OUT REACH
AND AN IMPROVING -- UP POP --
THE UNDERSTANDING OF THE PROGRAM
AMONG THE POPULATION CAN ALSO
TARGET FUNDING TOWARDS REGIONS
WHERE THE INCIDENCE OF FOOD AND
SECURITY IS HIGHER.
NO DEVELOPING THIS PLAN YOU ONLY
HAVE A FEW WEEKS BEFORE MAYOR
VISION SO IT'S PROBABLY TOO LATE.
TO HAVE SOMETHING IN TIME FOR
FOR THE BUDGET SO THERE ARE TWO
OPTIONS FOR THE LEGISLATURE ONE
IS TO INVITE THE ADMINISTRATION
TO COME BACK WITH THE PROPOSAL
NEXT YEAR.
THE SECOND OPTION IS TO
APPROPRIATE THE FUNDING -- BUT
RECALL.
WERE DIRECT TO THE
ADMINISTRATION TO COME UP WITH
THE REVISED PLAN -- SAY BY
NOVEMBER.
A BEFORE THE RELEASE OF FUNDS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU STATE LIBRARIAN.
LUCAS FROM THE THE STATE LIBRARY --
THERE'S A GOOD DESCRIPTION OF
THE PROGRAM.
WHEN AND SENATOR MITCHELL CAME
TO US WITH THE IDEA I MEAN HER
INTENT WAS NOT TO GLOBAL LATE
RESOLVE THE FACT THAT? ONE OUT
OF FIVE SCHOOL KIDS TO GET --
REDUCED OR FREE LUNCH DURING THE
SCHOOL YEAR ARE GETTING A LUNCH
IN THE SUMMER.
WHAT WHAT SHE HAD SAID WAS THAT
A CATEGORY OF PLACES WHERE
PEOPLE GO AND I FORGET HOW MANY
DO YOU DO YOU HAVE THAT
SOMETHING LIKE TWO THOUSAND OR
THREE THOUSAND OF THESE?
SITES WHERE SUMMER LUNCHES ARE
SERVED AROUND THE STATE.
AND SO SENATOR MITCHELL'S PITCH
INITIALLY WAS WELL [inaudible]
THE THERE'S A AND THERE'S AN
INCREASING NUMBER OF PEOPLE
GOING TO LIBRARIES BECAUSE THEY
WANT TO GO TO LIBRARIES IT'S A
SAFE AND STIGMA OF FREE
ENVIRONMENT.
THE KIDS CAN NOT ONLY GET A FREE
MEAL -- BUT ALSO BENEFIT FROM
ALL THE COOL THINGS THAT ARE AT
ALL LIBRARY AND AND I'VE BEEN TO
SOME OF THESE AND IT'S ABOUT.
TEN TO ONE AND FOWLER -- EAST
PALO ALTO ONTARIO.
AND IN FOWLER FOR EXAMPLE THE
GROWERS CONTRIBUTED PALLETS OF
FOOD SO THE FAMILIES WOULD WALK
OUT THE KIDS WOULD BE YOU KNOW
LIKE.
PLANTING BEANS AND DIXIE CUPS
AND STUFF PRIOR TO GETTING THE
LUNCH THE PARENTS WERE SITTING
DOWN WITH.
IT WHAT I THINK OF HIS COMMUNITY
NAVIGATORS TO HELP THEM CONNECT
TO SOCIAL SERVICES AND WALK OUT
THE DOOR AND TAKE A PALETTE OF
FRESH PRODUCE WITH THEM.
AND IN ONTARIO. TO A PERSON
EVERYONE WHO WALKED OUT FROM
GETTING THE THE FREE MAIL WHICH
LIKE IF CALIFORNIA GETS THE
PEOPLE THERE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT PAYS FOR THE PAYS FOR
THE LUNCH.
EVERY SINGLE PERSON SAID WHERE
DO WE SIGN UP FOR SUMMER READING.
AND I MEAN WITH RESPECT TO MEAN
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT'S
GONNA HAPPEN THAT.
COMMUNITY CENTERS OR PLACES THAT
OUR NEXT -- HOMELESS SHELTERS
ARE SOME OF THE OTHER -- IT
INSTITUTIONS ARE FACILITIES THAT
SERVE SUMMER LUNCHES.
SO WOULD IT BE A GOOD THING TO
HAVE SOME KIND OF GLOBAL
STRATEGY.
YEAH BUT THAT WAS NOT THE INTENT
OF THIS PROPOSAL AND AND I WOULD
SAY TO ECHO WHAT CHRIS SAID.
I MEAN WHEN THIS PROPOSAL GOT
PUT IN THE BUDGET IT WAS BEFORE
THE NEW ADMINISTRATION.
SO.
I DON'T MEAN THIS MAINLY BUT IF
THERE'S ANYONE SITTING HERE AT
THE TABLE WHOSE TIGHT WITH THE
BUCKETS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO THEY WOULDN'T PUT
THIS AND IF IT WAS.
LIKE A PIG IN A POKE OR SOME
KIND OF A BOONDOGGLE THING.
SORRY I DIDN'T MEAN TO GO LONG.
OKAY I GUESS I'M NOT GONNA GET
THE PR JOB AT YOUR PLAN.
TAKING A PUP.
ALREADY WELL I I I I GUESS THAT
THAT NOTION HERE IS A SIMPLE ONE
IS.
TO MAXIMIZE OUR EXISTING --
MEALS PROGRAMS AND DRAWN AS MUCH
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
MONEY AS WE CAN.
TO BE KIDS IN THE SUMMER AND I
KNOW.
HERE IN SACRAMENTO I'M FAMILIAR
WITH LOCATIONS THAT HAVE THESE --
SUMMER MEALS PROGRAMS ARE LOCAL
LIBRARIES AND I HAVE SEEN THEM
FIRST HAND AND I THINK THEY'RE
THEY'RE VERY SUCCESSFUL TELLS TO
THE EXTENT THAT WE CAN.
DO THIS WITH A MILLION DOLLARS --
AT THE BECAUSE A REASONABLE --
PROPOSAL IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE
OPEN THANK YOU FOR THE MARY VICE.
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN ZIP BOOKS.
FOR THE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
THE TO BOOKS A PILOT PROJECT
THROUGH THE STATE LIBRARY --
THIS PROGRAM ALLOWS LIBRARY
PATRONS IN MORE RURAL AREAS OF
THE STATE TO PURCHASE NEW
MATERIALS WILL BECOME PART.
OF THE LIBRARY'S COLLECTION --
THERE AFTER A SIMILAR INVESTMENT
WAS MADE IN THE BUDGET ACT OF
TWENTY AND JUST FOR SOME CONTEXT
FOR THIS PROGRAM ALL THE WAY IT
WORKS IS PARTICIPATING LIBRARIES.
OTHER PATRONS DEMAND A BOOK THE
LIBRARIES -- PURCHASE THE BOOK
USUALLY BY ESTABLISHING A LINE
OF CREDIT.
THE STATE THEN UP PURCHASES THE
BOOK -- THAT'S THEN DELIVERED TO
THE PATRON WHO THEN RETURNS THE
BOOK TO THE LIBRARY -- IN THE
LIBRARY AT THAT POINT CAN DECIDE
TO MAINTAIN THE BOOK OR I SELL
THE BOOK THROUGH IT SOME
FOUNDATION.
OUR OUR ASSESSMENT HERE IS GOING
TO SOUND SOMEWHAT SIMILAR TO THE
PREVIOUS PROPOSAL AND A
RECOMMENDATION AS WELL.
BUT WE THINK THAT THE GOVERNOR
IS ALSO IDENTIFIED ANOTHER A KEY
ISSUE FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER WHICH IS -- PATRON
ACCESS TO LIBRARY RESOURCES --
IN LIBRARY JURISDICTIONS THAT
ARE RURAL AND HAVE BEEN A
RELATIVELY UNDER RESOURCE.
AND OF INSURING LIBRARY PATRONS
HAVE ACCESS TO THOSE RESOURCES
HAS BEEN A LONG STANDING STATE
GOAL AND IS CURRENTLY EXPRESSED
IN STATE LAW.
OUR CONCERNS ARE THIS PROPOSAL
IS THAT THERE WERE SOME KEY
CONSIDERATIONS THAT -- THE
PROPOSAL THAT WAS PROVIDED TO US --
LACKED.
THE FIRST CONSIDERATION WAS A
DATA ON THE EXTENT TO WHICH THIS
IS HAPPENING -- THAT LIBRARIES
ARE ABLE TO BE PATRON DEMANDS
WHICH LIBRARIES AND THE EXTENT
TO WHICH THE MAGNITUDE OF THE OF
THIS PROBLEM SO THAT WE CAN
BETTER UNDERSTAND IF THE PROGRAM
IS ADEQUATELY TARGETED OR THAT
IS TARGETING THE THE RIVER.
RIGHT LIBRARY JURISDICTIONS.
ON THE PROPOSAL ALSO OF DIDN'T
CONSIDER SOME -- ADDITIONAL
ALTERNATIVES THAT COULD BE USED
TO EXPAND ACCESS -- TO PATRONS
ARE RURAL AREAS OF THE STATE
SUCH AS EXPANDING THE USE OF
ELECTRONIC RESOURCES FOR EXAMPLE.
AND THEN IN ADDITION THE
PROPOSAL DIDN'T CONSIDER THE
LOCAL RESOURCES THAT LIBRARIES --
SOMETIMES HAVE TO TO PURCHASE
PRINT MATERIALS.
FROM THE DATA WE LOOKED AT
SUGGESTED THAT OF THE SIXTY NINE
WIPERS ARE CURRENTLY PARTICIPATE
IN THE BOOKS -- THEY SPEND ABOUT
TEN MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
OUGHT TO ACQUIRE PRINT MATERIALS
OBVIOUSLY THAT THAT ESTIMATE
VARIES BY LIBRARY JURISDICTION
SO SOME LIBRARIES HAVE MORE
RESOURCES THAN OTHERS WITHIN
THAT GROUP. TO TO PURCHASE THOSE
MATERIALS.
IN ADDITION WE HAD REQUESTED
SOME HISTORICAL DATA ON THE
PROGRAM THE PROGRAM'S BEEN
AROUND FOR A FEW YEARS AT LEAST
SINCE IT'S BEEN RECEIVING STATE
FUNDING -- SO THAT WE CAN ASSESS
WHETHER THE THE CURRENT QUEST AS
IS REASONABLE AND WE WE HAVEN'T
RECEIVED THAT DATA REQUEST YET
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THAT.
I'M THE GIVEN THESE CONCERNS WE
ALSO RECOMMENDED THAT.
OTHERS NEED THE LEGISLATURE
DIRECT THE STATE LIBRARY IN THE
ADMINISTRATION TO COME BACK WITH
A A FOR PROPOSAL -- AS SIMILAR
TO OUR RECOMMENDATION IN THE
LUNCH THE LIBRARY PROGRAM THE
LEGISLATURE COULD EITHER DO THIS
BY INVITING THE ADMINISTRATION
TO RETURN NEXT YEAR OR A
CONDITIONING THE RELEASE OF THE
FUNDS ON GETTING -- ON UPDATED
PLAN -- AT NOVEMBER THANK YOU.
REGULAR BECAUSE FROM THAT STATE
LIBRARY AGAIN -- WELL AS JASON
SAID THE PROGRAM'S BEEN AROUND%
FOR FOUR OR FIVE YEARS IT BEGAN
AS A PILOT PROJECT IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA.
AS A WAY TO IMPROVE CUSTOMER
SERVICE SO THERE'S BUT 20% OF
CALIFORNIA WHERE IT'S A BIG DEAL
TO GO AND THE TOWN.
AND SO THE THINKING BEHIND THIS
WAS TO IMPROVE CUSTOMER SERVICE.
AND REDUCE THE COSTS FOR
LIBRARIES.
AND THERE'S THERE'S A GREEN SORT
OF BENEFIT AS WELL THE
TRADITIONAL METHOD OF GETTING
THESE BOOKS AS YOU CALL THE
LIBRARY THEY THEY TALK TO
ANOTHER LIBRARY SOMEWHERE ELSE
USUALLY A LARGER DIRT
JURISDICTION.
THAT PUTS THEM ON A TRUCK AND
SENDS -- IT TAKES ABOUT TWO
WEEKS TO DELIVER -- IS JUST A
COUPLE -- JASON POINTED OUT THAT
THERE ARE ELECTRONIC
ALTERNATIVES TO THIS -- ONE OF
THEM WAS WHICH DOES WORK IN SOME
PARTS OF THE STATE WHERE YOU
TAKE THE CATALOGS OF ALL THESE
DIFFERENT LIBRARIES AND MERGE
THEM SO IF I AM IN -- GRASS
VALLEY INSTEAD OF JUST SEEING
THE BOOKS THAT ARE IN THE GRASS
VALLEY LIBRARY I'D SEE THE BOOKS
THAT ARE IN SORT OF GREATER ALTA
CALIFORNIA.
AND THIS COMMITTEE THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR BROWN
PUT UP FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET. TO CONNECT EVERY
LIBRARY NORTH OF SACRAMENTO WITH
LINK PLUS.
AND ULTIMATELY ONLY THREE
LIBRARIES DECIDED TO DO THAT
BECAUSE OF THE ONGOING EXPENSE
OF THE PROGRAM WHICH IS ABOUT
TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IN ANNUAL SUBSCRIPTION COSTS AND
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE
LIBRARIES SENDS US AND ME
PERSONALLY IN THE LIBRARY
GENERALLY -- CONSTANT EMAILS A
STEADY STREAM OF EMAILS AND
NOTES THAT SAY PLEASE CONTINUE
THE ZIP BOOKS MONEY WE LOVE IT
BECAUSE IT'S LESS EXPENSIVE AND
LESS HASSLE FOR US IN THE
LIBRARY.
AND OUR CUSTOMERS THINK IT'S
TERRIFIC.
AND FINALLY -- LAST WEEK WE HAD
ALL THE PUBLIC LIBRARY DIRECTORS
IN CALIFORNIA UP IN SACRAMENTO
FOR A CONFERENCE AND SO IN THE
HALL IN THE FOYER.
OUTSIDE OF THE ROOM THEY WERE
MEETING WE HAD POSTERS OF THE
VARIOUS PROGRAMS THE STATE
LIBRARY DOES THE EXERCISE WAS.
TO GO AND PUT A POST IT ON EACH
OF THE PROGRAMS THAT YOU LOVE OR
THAT YOU FIND OR USE.
AND THERE WERE SO MANY POSTED ON
THE ZIP B<c.cyan> PROGRAM THAT SAID</c>
THE LOVE THAT YOU COULDN'T
REALLY TELL THAT IT WAS OF BOOKS.
THE DEFENSE RESTS.
YOUR WRITING WELL THIS IS AN
INTRIGUING PROPOSAL I WILL NOTE
THAT LAST WEEK WAS A TAKE YOUR
DAUGHTER TO WORK DAY.
SO MY DAUGHTER BARBARA CAME TO
MY IN MY OFFICE AND SHE WAS
THERE FOR MY BRIEFING WITH MY
BUDGET -- CHIEF BUDGET STAFFER
HERE MISTER MARTIN AND SO SHE
WAS HERE ABOUT THE ZIP PROPOSAL.
SO SHE WENT HOME WHICH IS
TALKING ABOUT AND SHE THOUGHT
THAT WAS A GOOD IDEA SO. FOR
WHAT IT'S WORTH -- IT WE GOT TO
DO A PR CAMPAIGN FOR THAT BABIES
WITH A BETTER JOB THAN YOU
MISTER LUCAS.
I HAVE NO DOUBT SHE WOULD.
ALREADY WE WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE --
OPEN.
AND WE'LL PROCEED NOW WITH ISSUE
NUMBER.
EIGHT STATE GRANTS WEB PORTAL.
CERTAINLY ASSEMBLY BILL --
TWENTY TWO FIFTY TWO WHICH WAS
SIGNED IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
REQUIRED THE STATE LIBRARY -- TO
ESTABLISHED A BROAD INTERNET WEB
PORTAL FOR FUNDING GRANT
OPPORTUNITIES THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET I IN RECOGNITION OF THAT
LEGISLATION -- BEING SIGNED UP
PROPOSES OR THAT THE APRIL
LETTER THAT AS A PROPOSED A
600-401-0004 THE LIBRARY TO
DEVELOP THE GREG GENERAL FUND TO
DEVELOP THE GRANT PORTHOLE --
AND MAKE THAT AVAILABLE OF THAT
600-401-0002 HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND IT'SONE TIME -- AND
THE REMAINDER WOULD -- SUPPORT
THE LIBRARIES CONTINUED
OPERATION OF THE GRANT PORTABLE
AS WELL AS WORKING WITH STATE
AGENCIES TO OBTAIN THE
INFORMATION THAT WOULD BE PLACED
ON TO THAT WEBSITE AND THAT
PORTAL.
THE ONE ISSUE FOR CONSIDERATION
WOULD RAISE FOR THE COMMITTEE
WOULD BE THE ON GOING NEED FOR
STAFF -- ONCE THE WEB PORTAL
BECOME COMES ONLINE -- IN ORDER
TO IMPLEMENT THIS PROJECT THERE
IT IS LIKELY GOING TO BE
CONSIDERABLE WORKLOAD THIS STATE
LIBRARY HAS TO ENTER INTO
AGREEMENTS WITH MULTIPLE STATE
AGENCIES. TO AND TO ENSURE THAT
THE WEB PORTAL WAS USABLE THAT
THEY HAVE TO COORDINATE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE IT'S
USABLE.
I'M AND THEN IN ADDITION THEY
HAVE TO DEVELOP A WEB PORTAL
THAT -- WILL -- COORDINATE WITH
OTHER WEBSITES AMONG STATE
AGENCIES AND SO THAT WOULD BE
THAT DEPRIVE THE OF WORKLOAD TO
DEVELOP THAT WE WE THOUGHT TO
POSITION SEEM JUSTIFIED.
IN A FEW YEARS THERE THERE COULD
ALSO BE SOME ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD --
THE STATE LIBRARY INDICATES THAT
THERE WILL PROBABLY NEED TO BE
ENTERED OF IMPROVEMENTS MADE TO
THE WEBSITE.
AFTER COMES ONLINE THERE COULD
BE ADDITIONAL AGREEMENTS THAT
HAVE TO BE ENTERED INTO.
I'M OUR QUESTION WAS EVENTUALLY
ONCE IT TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
STATE LIBRARY'S ABLE TO AUTOMATE
THIS WEB PORTAL IN THE LONG RUN --
COULD THAT COULD THERE BE A
CONTINUED I NEED TO HAVE -- TO
PERMANENT POSITIONS. TO THAT END
WE WE WOULD NORMALLY RECOMMEND --
OF THE LEGISLATURE PROVIDING
LIMITED TERM FUNDING AND AND
REVISITING WORKLOAD DEMANDS IN A
FEW YEARS TO COME CONTINUE TO
ENSURE THAT THE WORKLOAD IS
JUSTIFIED.
NOW WHEN WE BROUGHT THIS UP WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION ONE CONCERN
IT RAISED WAS THE ABILITY OF THE
STATE LIBRARY.
TO FILL THESE POSITIONS --
ANECDOTALLY SOME -- AGENCIES
HAVE A HAVE VACANCIES WHEN THEY
HAVE LIMITED TERM POSITIONS.
AND SO IF THAT WORK IN FRONT OF
THE LEGISLATURE AND WERE TO WANT --
TO PROVIDE THE FUNDING ON A
LIMITED TERM BASIS IT COULD WORK
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE
STATE LIBRARY TO ENSURE -- THE
EXISTING STATUTORY DEADLINES ARE
ARE REASONABLE IN CAN BE MET
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU WE'RE GOING TO
HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN FOR THE MAY
REVISION WE KNOW THIS IS MUCH.
AN ISSUE THAT'S BASED UPON
LEGISLATION SIGNED INTO LAW LAST
YEAR SO IT IS WHAT IT IS OKAY
THANK YOU WERE GOING TO PROCEED
NOW WITH HASTINGS COLLEGE OF LAW
.
THE MORNING JAX.
THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS THE
SAVINGS BECAUSE OF LOS BUDGET
WITH YOU THIS MORNING.
UC HASTINGS IS AFFILIATED WITH
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SYSTEM BUT IS GOVERNED BY ITS
OWN BOARD OF GOVERNORS.
LOCATED IN SAN FRANCISCO THAT
FROM IRA PRIMARILY SERVE
STUDENTS SEEKING INTEREST DOCTOR
DEGREE.
BUT ALSO AS A MASTER OF LOS
PROGRAMMING A MASTERS OF STUDIES
IN LAW PROGRAM -- IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN UC HASTINGS
AND ROLLED NINE HUNDRED THIRTY
FOUR FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
STUDENTS OF THESE EIGHT EARNED
FIFTEEN WHERE JD STUDENTS.
ANNUAL TUITION FOR ITS JURIS
DOCTOR PROGRAM THIS YEAR.
IS 440-003-0020 SIX DOLLARS.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN YOU
SAY SIX TOTAL BUDGET FUNDED
PRIMARILY BY GENERAL FUND IN
TUITION FEES.
IS EIGHTY NINE POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS WITH THE AMOUNT OF
GENERAL FUNDING NINETEEN POINT
EIGHT MILLION.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES A TWO
POINT 5% AUGMENTATION DC
HASTINGS.
THIS REPRESENTED AN INCREASE OF
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION ONGOING
GENERAL FUND.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
ALSO INCLUDES ONE MILLION.
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
UC HASTINGS DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
NEEDS IN TOTAL THE GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATIONS THE COLLEGE WILL
BE SIXTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LA -- SO YOU HAVE TO
PROPOSALS BEFORE YOU WITH REGARD
TO THE HASTINGS COLLEGE OF ALL
THE FIRST IS THE BASE INCREASE
AND THE SECOND IS THE ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
ALL ADDRESS EACH AS SHE WANTED A
TIME.
WITH REGARD TO THE BASE INCREASE
WE DON'T HAVE A HARD
RECOMMENDATION ON TO ADOPTING
MODIFYING OR REJECTING THE
PROPOSAL.
BUT WE DO CONTINUE TO ENCOURAGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO KEEP HASTINGS
OVERALL BUDGET CONDITION IN MIND --
AND IT'S A SIGNAL TO THE LAW
SCHOOL AT THE LEGISLATURE'S
INTENTIONS REGARDING COST
INCREASES AND TUITION INCREASES
AS THESE FACTORS WILL --
INFLUENCE A SCHOOL'S ABILITY --
TO ELIMINATE ITS BUDGET DEFICIT
OVER THE REMAINDER OF THE PERIOD.
AS A AS AN UPDATE THE LAW SCHOOL
HAS REGULARLY.
UP SUBMITTED TO US FIVE YEAR
PLANS TO ELIMINATE THIS DEFICIT
I'M IN THIS MOST RECENT PLANNED
THE LAW SCHOOL.
DISSIPATES ELIMINATING THIS
DEFICIT BY -- TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE THAT'S ABOUT ONE
YEAR LONGER THAN A WHAT THE LAW
SCHOOL HAD ANTICIPATED FOR LAST
YEAR.
ON THAT PLAN.
THE MOSTLY ELIMINATES THE
DEFICIT BY -- AT LEAST THE
VERSION THAT WE'VE SEEN AND IT'S
A PLAN THAT THAT CHANGES.
YOU KNOW FROM TIME TO TIME BUT
THE THE PLAN THAT WE'VE SEEN.
ASSUMED -- TUITION INCREASES
BEGINNING AND TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE I'M IN THE IN FROM OF
THE LIMITING THIS DEFICIT THE
LAW SCHOOL ANTICIPATES.
COVERING THIS DEFICIT THROUGH
ITS RESERVES OF THE LAW SCHOOL
ANTICIPATED WILL START -- HAVING
SPENT DOWN ITS OPERATING GENERAL
OPERATING RESERVE AND WILL STOP
START -- COVERING BECAUSE
THEY'RE MEAN IT REMAINED OR
DEFICIT WITH IT SO RESERVE
THAT'S A DESIGNATED -- FOR
BUILDING MAINTENANCE.
WE WOULD NOTE THAT WHEN THE
SCHOOL STARTED DEFICIT SPENDING
IT WAS A PERIOD OF TIME WHEN THE
ECONOMY WAS STRONG AND THE
SCHOOL RECEIVING BASE INCREASES --
WERE THE STATE TO EXPERIENCE A
RECESSION -- CORRECTING OF
HASTINGS BUDGET DEFICIT COULD
POSE RISKS THE LEGISLATURE AND
COULD RESULT IN.
POTENTIALLY MORE DIFFICULT
DECISIONS SUCH AS HIGHER TUITION
INCREASES FOR STUDENTS FOR
EXAMPLE SO THAT'S WHY WE
ENCOURAGE LEGISLATURE REVIEW
THIS PLANET INSURANCE
COMFORTABLE WITH.
OTHER SECTIONS THE SCHOOLS
MAKING.
WITH REGARD TO THE SECOND
PROPOSAL DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
I'M AS YOU'VE HEARD OUR OFFICE A
MANY TIMES THROUGHOUT YOUR
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING SO WE
GENERALLY FIND DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE TO BE A HIGH
PRIORITY FOR ONE TIME FUNDING.
IN THIS CASE WE RECOMMEND
REJECTING THE PROPOSAL.
ON A REASONS ARE TWO FOLD THE
FIRST IS THAT.
A SCHOOL -- OF ITS REMAINING
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG A PORTION OF
THOSE PROJECTS ARE SOMEWHAT
LOWER PRIORITY -- FOR EXAMPLE --
INTERIOR REPAINTING AND
CARPETING REPLACEMENT -- SOME OF
THE SOME OTHER PROJECTS ARE ARE
MORE REGULAR CRITICAL BUILDING
OPERATIONS LIKE I'LL.
ELEVATOR CONTROLS FOR EXAMPLE SO
THERE'S A MIX -- ON TERMS OF THE
A CRITICALITY OF THOSE PROJECTS
THE SECOND.
REASON WHY RECOMMEND REJECTING
IS THAT THE SCHOOL HAS --
RESERVES DESIGNATED FOR BUILDING
MAINTENANCE WE THINK THOSE WOULD
BE APPROPRIATE FUND SOURCE TO
ADDRESS THEIR REMAINING
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU.
A STINGS REPRESENTATIVE -- DAVID
FAKE MEN ON THE DEAN IT --
HASTINGS COLLEGE OF THE LAW --
WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET -- IN TERMS OF
THE REDUCTION OF ENROLLMENT OVER
THE LAST -- FOUR TO FIVE YEARS --
THAT WAS A CONSIDERED DECISION
OF THE COLLEGE -- IT FOLLOWS --
WHAT IS HAPPENING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THAT ALTHOUGH WE HADN'T
ECONOMIC EXPANSION -- WE HAVE
NOT HAD THAT CANNOT BE EXPANSION
IN THE NUMBER OF LAW JOBS OR THE
NUMBER OF LAW SCHOOL
APPLICATIONS.
AND SO AS FOR TO ALL THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA LAW
SCHOOLS HAVE DONE AND VIRTUALLY
ALL THE LAW SCHOOLS AROUND THE
COUNTRY HAVE DONE -- IS THAT
WE'VE TAKEN THE RESPONSIBLE
ROUTE -- REDUCING THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS ABOUT 20% -- IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THAT OUR GRADUATES
HAVE GOOD OPPORTUNITIES -- IN
THE EMPLOYMENT MARKET -- THAT IS
ACTUALLY PART OF A MUCH GREATER
PLAN -- AS YOU KNOW OF COURSE
THAT WE ARE QUITE GRATEFUL FOR
THE GENEROSITY OF THE STATE AND
ALLOCATING FUNDS TO BUILD A NEW
ACADEMIC BUILDING -- THAT WILL
BE COMPLETED THIS DECEMBER --
THAT GIVES US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DEMOLISH AND BUILD A ON OUR OLD
ACADEMIC BUILDING SITE -- THAT
BUILDING WILL BE A FOURTEEN
STORY -- MIXED USE BUILDING --
IT WILL HAVE A REPLACEMENT
ACADEMIC SPACE -- BUT ALSO HAVE
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED AND THIRTY
UNITS THE STUDENT HOUSING --
THOSE UNISYS JUNE HOUSING WILL
BE SHARED -- WITH YOU CASF SOME
WITH LIKELY WITH UNIVERSE
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY -- AND THAT
WILL ALSO THEN GIVE US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RENOVATE -- OUR
HOUSING STRUCTURE -- SO WE WILL
BE MOVING FROM HOUSING ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY GRADUATE
STUDENTS LAW STUDENTS TO HOUSING
OVER -- THOUSAND GRADUATE
STUDENTS BUT WOULD WHICH ONE
COULD ABOUT 40% PLUS -- UCSF
GRADUATE STUDENTS THAT -- SO
THIS IS BUILDING -- WHAT I
DESCRIBED AS AN ACADEMIC VILLAGE
IN THE HEART OF SAN FRANCISCO --
WE WILL NOT BE INCREASING THE
SIZE OF OUR JD CLASS BUT WILL BE --
COLLABORATING WITH AND
PARTNERING WITH OF THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA CAMPUSES --
TO HAVE THIS VERY VIBRANT
ENERGETIC -- VILLAGE IN THE
TENDERLOIN CIVIC CENTER MID
MARKET AREA OF SAN FRANCISCO.
I ALSO HAD M. COMPANY BY MY
CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER DAVID
STEWART WHO CAN SPEAK MORE
DIRECTLY TO SOME OF THE
FINANCIAL ISSUES.
OKAY WITH REGARDS TO THE THAT
THE DEFICIT -- I UNDERSTAND THIS
IS PART OF A LARGER.
ISSUE LAW SCHOOLS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AS WELL AS ART ARE YOU
SEE LAW SCHOOLS AND YOU HAVE THE
BENEFIT OR HE IS NOT THE ENVY OF
BEING SINGLED OUT HERE TODAY AS
OPPOSED TO WE DON'T.
HAVE HEARINGS ON YOU SEE.
IRVINE -- BERKLEE COLLEGE OF LAW
BUT YOU YOU'RE HERE TODAY
BECAUSE YOUR SEPARATE OF COURSE
IN THE A BUDGET THAT OUR STATE
CONSTITUTION.
SO.
I GUESS SINCE YOU ARE HERE TODAY --
YOU KNOW HOW HOW CAN YOU ASSURE
US THIS IS NOT GOING TO CONTINUE
TO BE AT A DRIP DRIP BECAUSE YOU
KNOW WANT ONLY A MILLION BUCKS.
YOU KNOW WE HEARD EARLIER THAT.
STUDENTS WHEN YOU SEND THE
AUDIENCE ARE SLEEPING IN THEIR
CARS.
AND ARE TRYING TO GO TO COLLEGE
IN.
IN THIS WILL KIND OF A LUXURY
WHEN YOU ASK THAT MANY PEOPLE
ABOUT.
OUR OUR LAW SCHOOLS THROUGHOUT
OUR OUR STATE OR COUNTRY SO HOW
CAN WE BE ASSURED THAT THIS IS
NOT CONNECTED TO BE A DRAIN ON
OUR SCARCE RESOURCES WELL FIRST
WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE POINTS RAISED BY LET
GENERALIST -- SOME OF THE THE
NUMBERS IN THIS REPORT ARE --
INACCURATE SO WE DO NOT HAVE AN
UPGRADE TO A FACT CHECK PRIOR TO
THE RELEASE OF THE REPORT -- BUT
THE CONCERNS RAISED ABOUT THE
EXISTENCE OF THE ADEQUACY OF OUR
RESERVES -- WE WILL HAVE A FOUR
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN
OPERATING RESERVES AS OF THE END
OF THE WEEK -- BEGINNING OF
FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY I WILL
END OF FISCAL YEAR WITH OF
ANOTHER FIVE POINT NINE MILLION
AND PLAN FOR RESERVE OR
MAINTENANCE RESERVES FOR TOLL
RESERVES OF TEN MILLION DOLLARS
WE WILL NOT BE FULLY EXPANDING
OUR OPERATING RESERVES AT THE
END OF NINETEEN TWENTY AS
INDICATED IN THE RECOMMENDATION.
OF THAT SAID A RESERVE HAVE BEEN
DEPLOYED CHIU OF SUPPORT OUR
FINANCIAL AID STRATEGIES ARE PUT
IN THIS COUNTY STRATEGIES TO
ALLOW US TO BE COMPETITIVE.
AND TO SUPPORT A LOWER
ENROLLMENT OF MORE CLOSELY
ALIGNED TO THE EMPLOYMENT
PRADHAN BUTTONS WERE STUDENTS --
WE DO HAVE A PLAN TO ADDRESS
THAT DEFICIT WE SHARE IT WITH
THE COMMITTEE ON AN ANNUAL BASIS --
LAST YEAR YOU MAY RECALL OF SOME
OF THE ASSUMPTIONS FOR USE OF
WERE.
QUESTION AND I THOUGHT
APPROPRIATELY ONE OF SOME.
WE INITIALLY HAD PROPOSAL.
GRAHAM TO A 10% PAY INCREASE.
UPON INPUT FROM THIS COMMITTEE
WE FEEL THAT DOWN 25%.
AND SUPPOSEDLY TO THE GOOGLE
SHARES OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WERE ABLE TO AVOID THE
FEE INCREASE TOTALLY FOR EIGHTH
CONSECUTIVE YEAR -- AS TO
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
[inaudible]
THE THE ALLOCATION OF FUNDS
BETWEEN.
OPERATING AND DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PLANT FUND.
IS TOTALLY OF THOSE DOLLARS ARE
FUNGIBLE THE BOTH UNRESTRICTED
FUNDS THEY CAN USE FOR OTHER
PURPOSES.
AND WE DO TAKE CARE AND
MAINTAINING OUR FACILITIES.
OF BECAUSE IT IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT FOR THE INSTITUTION
AN TO PROVIDE THE EXPERIENCE AT
OUR STUDENTS EXPECT -- WE WILL
BE BALANCING OUR BUDGET.
AND DOING SO WITH A COMBINATION
OF COST REDUCTIONS AND YOU KNOW
HOPEFULLY SOME REVENUE GROWTH.
EITHER THROUGH A GENERAL FUND OR
IF NECESSARY TO FOR A FUTURE
STUDENT PLEASE.
AGAIN WE ARE GOING INTO OUR
EIGHTH CONSECUTIVE YEAR AND
WE'RE VERY PLEASED ABOUT THAT
YEAH BUT THE BIGGER QUESTION HOW
CAN YOU REASSURE US THAT.
THIS IS NOT GOING TO CONTINUE TO
BE.
A OUT AND ASKING THAT A DRAG ON
THE STATE BUDGET.
OF THE FUNDING AUGMENTATIONS
THAT WE DO RECEIVE ARE YOU KNOW
FOR IN -- CONSISTENT WITH THOSE
OF FORTITUDE TO SEE IF YOU AND
IF THE SYSTEM -- IT'S
EFFECTIVELY A OF OF COLA
ADJUSTMENT ANOTHER CALL ABOUT
THAT THEIR YOUR DEFICIT AND
HAVING TO I UNDERSTAND THAT --
WE'RE WE ARE WE WE ARE SELF
SUFFICIENT WE HAVE ALL THE FORMS
OF REVENUE THAT ARE NOT
REFLECTED IN THE ANNALS RESOURCE
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION THE ON
GOING HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
YOUR DEFICIT.
OF THE ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
HELPS US FUND OUR OPERATING
COSTS FOR THE UPCOMING YEAR YEAH
OF THE PLAY COMPENSATION.
COST GROWTH.
AND AFTER THAT ONE POINT
FORMALLY NO OBLIGATION AYE AYE
CLEARLY ARE DEFICIT WOULD
INCREASE.
SO WE ARE APPRECIATIVE IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
AND BELIEVE THAT THE WORKLOAD
ADJUSTMENT THAT'S BEEN PROVIDED.
IS -- IT EQUITABLE IN PARITY
WITH THE UC AND CSU OKAY THANK
YOU [inaudible]
MR MURATSUCHI.
THANK YOU I ALSO ECHO THE CHAIRS --
SYMPATHY THEN THE HASTINGS HAS
ITS OWN SEPARATE BUDGET AND SO.
YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT -- A RELATIVELY SMALL
AMOUNT OF OF OF MONEY HERE BUT
BECAUSE YOU ARE REPRESENTATIVE.
YOU'RE THE ONLY OPTION THAT WE
HAVE TO TO HEAR WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH OUR UNIVERSE A CALIFORNIA
LAW SCHOOLS LIKE THAT I JUST HAD
A FEW QUESTIONS SO.
FIRST OF ALL IT WHAT IS THE THE
CURRENT -- TUITION FOR LAW
SCHOOL -- ARE WHAT SCHOOL
TUITION ABOUT -- FORTY FOUR
THREE WE ARE CURRENTLY BELOW ALL
THE AT THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
LAW SCHOOLS -- VERY VERY --
ABOUT ONE TO FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS ABOUT OUR NUMBER.
OKAY AND SO THAT THAT TUITION IS
THE SAME WHETHER YOU'RE IN STATE
OR OUT OF STATE -- NO I JUST THE
COSTS ABOUT SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS
MORE SIX THOUSAND MORE OKAY.
AND I I SEE IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THAT -- YOU HAVE A
TUITION DISCOUNT [inaudible]
AND THE YES.
SO HISTORICALLY WE WERE BETWEEN
TWENTY FIVE AND 30% TUITION
DISCOUNT WHICH IS -- BASICALLY
TO SUPPORT BOTH NEED AND MERIT --
DURING THE LEAN YEARS OF
APPLICATIONS -- MOST AW SCHOOLS
IN THE COUNTRY -- BEGAN TO UP
THAT AMOUNT -- SO SCHOOLS LIKE --
DAVIS AND IRVINE PARTICULAR --
WHEN UP TO ABOUT 505560% TUITION
DISCOUNT -- GIVEN OUR RESOURCES
WE WENT UP -- BETWEEN FORTY AND
FORTY FIVE BUT GIVEN THE BUDGET
SITUATION WE ARE NOW WATCHING
THAT BACK -- TOWARD THE 30% 28% --
HISTORICAL NORM.
ACCORDING TO THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THESE TUITION DISCOUNTS
ARE ALLOCATED TO STUDENTS
PRIMARILY BASED ON MERIT RATHER
THAN.
FINANCIAL NEED IS A AS AN
ACTRESS.
IT'S A BIT OF A MIX -- ABOUT
85290% OF OUR STUDENTS HAD NEED --
SO EVEN WHEN WE ARE REWARDING I
KNOW IT -- IT'S VERY OFTEN GOING
TO STUDENTS WHO HAVE NEED -- IN
PARTICULAR AS WAS DISCUSSED --
IN THE EARLIER PRESENTATION --
THE COST OF LIVING IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND THEN THE TO
SUPPORTER NON TUITION -- ASPECTS
OF OUR STUDENT NEEDS BECAUSE OF
COURSE QUITE COMPELLING AS WELL
OKAY.
AND THEN YOU TALKED ABOUT HOW --
YOU'RE LOOKING AT ENROLLMENT
NUMBERS GOING DOWN 20% -- OVER
THE NEXT.
THREE ACCORDING TO THE COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCES THE WRITTEN ANALYSIS.
NEXT THREE YEARS -- NOT OVER THE
NEXT THE YEAR WAS OVER THE PAST
FIVE YEARS OVER THE PAST BY WE
ARE TARGET -- CURRENTLY IS
AROUND THREE HUNDRED AND THREE
UNDER -- TWENTY WE EXPECT THAT
THE HOLD STEADY -- IN IN THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE.
WITH WITH THE ENTERING CLASS
SAID IN A CLASS WILL BE LIKELY
AROUND THREE TEN AT THREE TWENTY
AND THAT WILL CONTINUE -- FOR
THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE.
YEAH WE HAVE NO PLANS TO REDUCE
THAT ALLOWS FOR THE CLASS
[inaudible]
OKAY -- AND AND YOU TALK ABOUT
HOW THIS IS THE GENERAL TREND
WITH LAW SCHOOLS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY BECAUSE OF THEIR THE
LEGAL JOB MARKET EXACTLY A HIGH --
I I GUESS MY MY CONCERN YOU KNOW
FOR MY EXPERIENCE TO HAVE A
HAVING GONE TO UCLA LAW SCHOOL
IS THAT -- YEAH I I I DON'T.
IT SEEMS TO ME LIKE THE **** THE
LEGAL JOB MARKET IS IS PRIMARILY
DRIVEN BY THE THE CORPORATE LAW
FIRMS AND IT'S NOT DRIVEN BY THE
LACK OF GOOD PUBLIC SERVICE
LAWYERS THAT THAT WOULD PROVIDE
LIKE SAY.
YOU KNOW WITH THE ADVICE
IMMIGRATION ADVICE. FOR FOUR
FOUR IF A FAMILY STUCK AT THE
BORDER -- OUR OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER OR YOU KNOW THE MANY
OTHER NEEDS THAT THAT THAT WE
CAN THINK OF WHERE WHERE LAWYERS
CAN BE -- YOU KNOW VERY VERY
USEFUL AND AND SO.
WHAT IS HASTINGS DOING YOU KNOW?
WHAT WHEN WHEN I SEE ON?
WAIT WHEN WHEN I SEE MOST OF OF
OF LAW SCHOOL GRADUATES GOING TO
WORK IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR
RATHER THAN WHILE WORKING AND
PUBLIC SERVICE JOBS AND I I
DON'T THINK THAT THE THE THE THE
IT SEEMS TO ME LIKE A LIKE BE.
ENROLLMENT DECISIONS ARE BEING
DRIVEN PRIMARILY BY THE PRIVATE
LEGAL JOB MARKET RATHER THAN THE
THE THE PUBLIC JOB MARKET BANG I
WANT TO GIVE YOU.
A CHANCE TO RESPOND.
AND I THINK THAT'S AN
INTERESTING OBSERVATION I THINK
IT SUBMITS BAD -- WE HAVE ABOUT
35240% OF OUR STUDENTS GOING
INTO A SO CALLED BIG LAW WHICH
MIGHT BE MORE ONE HUNDRED LAW
FIRMS -- BUT OF COURSE HASTENS
HAS A GREAT TRADITION OF
SUPPLYING OF PUBLIC SERVICE
PUBLIC INTEREST ATTORNEYS I WE
HAVE A NUMBER NUMBER CENTERS YOU
MENTIONED IMMIGRATION -- WE HAVE
THE SENDER CENTER FOR GENDER AND
REFUGEE STUDIES RUN BY COUNTY
SALO -- WHO DOES EXACTLY WHAT
YOU DESCRIBE WHICH IS THE SUN
WARRIORS TO THE BORDER -- TO
HELP -- SEPARATED FAMILIES -- TO
REPRESENT -- DHAKA -- STUDENTS
AND AND SO ON AND OF COURSE JEFF
ADACHI WAS A GRADUATE OF
HASTINGS -- COMMA HARRIS OF
BETTER THE HASTINGS WILL YOU
KNOW -- WILLIE BROWN WASN'T
GRADUATE HASTINGS -- SO QUITE
PROUD OF OF THE PUBLIC SERVICE --
THAT OUR OUR GRADUATES A GUN --
I WOULD SAY TODAY -- HOUR OR MIX
NOT BE HAPPY TO ACTUALLY SUPPLY
THOSE THOSE NUMBERS FOR YOU --
IN IN IN WRITING -- IS A MIX OF
BIG LAW FIRMS BUT RECALL FROM
JACKSON NOT HIRING AS MUCH FROM
STRAIGHT FROM LAW SCHOOL OTHER
CHRISLEY HIGHER LATERALS AND SO
A LOT OF OUR STUDENTS JUST
STARTING IN SMALLER LAW FIRMS --
AND ACTUALLY MANY YEARS STARTING
DOWN A CORPORATE WELL LAW
DEPARTMENTS BUT I I DON'T SEE I
MEAN IF IF THEY'RE PAYING FORTY
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS IN IN A
TUITION A YEAR I I ASSUME THERE.
YOU KNOW A A WHAT THE THAT'S A
OVER A HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND
WHEN THEY GRADUATE.
I MEAN I WOULD I WAS PAYING
SEVEN THOUSAND A YEAR WHEN I
WENT TO LAW SCHOOL IN IN IN IN
THE NINETIES.
I DON'T SEE HOW YOU CAN ANYONE
CAN GOING TO PUBLIC SERVICE.
YOU KNOW WITH A HUNDRED THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS -- TUITION BILL
NOW THERE ARE PUBLIC INTEREST
LOAN FORGIVENESS PROGRAMS AND
AND HOW MANY.
HOW MANY STUDENTS AT HASTINGS
RECEIVE I HAVE THE EXACT NUMBER
BUT THEN THE TO BUT I'D BE HAPPY
TO SUPPLY THAT -- BUT MANY -- DO --
VIRTUALLY ALL THAT GOING PUBLIC
CONTRAST -- SEEK IT OUT IF THEY
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT THAT -- BUT
EXACTLY YOUR OBSERVATION -- AND
I'M SURE YOU HAVE FROM JENNIFER
MENU CAM -- AS AN ALARM AT UCLA
THAT -- MANY OF OUR ALUMNI WENT
TO SCHOOL IN THE SEVENTIES
EIGHTIES AND NINETIES WHEN -- WE
WERE HEAVILY SUBSIDIZED BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- AND WE DO
SAID WELL AND I THIS IS THE TIME
TO GET BACK AND SO WE DO ASK OUR
ALUMNI JUST BY -- SCHOLARSHIPS
AND SUPPORT -- THAT WOULD HELP
THE STUDENTS GRADUATE WITH MUCH
LESS THAN -- THEN IF THEY'RE
PAYING.
FULL FULL FREIGHT.
I I GUESS I WOULD JUST SEND A
MISTER CHAIR I YOU KNOW WHERE
EVER SINCE MY DAYS WITH THE WITH
THE LAW SCHOOL AND AND AND AND
JUST SEEING THE THE YOU KNOW.
EXTREMELY HIGH TUITION COSTS
THAT THAT ARE BEING CHARGED TO
OUR PROFESSIONAL STUDENTS
INCLUDING LAW STUDENTS.
THAT.
IT SEEMS TO ME LIKE.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING HASTINGS SHOULD BE
FOCUSING MORE ON EDUCATING
ATTORNEYS TO GO INTO PUBLIC
SERVICE.
AND NOT NECESSARILY TO BE
PROVIDING -- YOU KNOW.
BUT WHAT IT WHAT I ASSUME IS IS
STILL A A CHEAPER ALTERNATIVE TO
TWO PRIVATE LAW SCHOOLS.
YOU KNOW TO TO BE EDUCATING GO
LAWYERS. FOR FOR FOR CORPORATE
LAW FIRMS.
WELL HE COMES.
WITH A SOLUTION AND PROPOSAL.
IT WILL TAKE A LOOK AT THAT BUT
I I THINK YOU RAISE AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND ONE THING I FIND
INTERESTING.
MISTER ICE WHICH IS IF YOU LOOK
AT SAN FRANCISCO'S AND THE CSU
DEBATE.
SAN FRANCISCO STATE IS SEPARATE
TOPIC HERE IS IS ONE THE
UNIVERSITIES WERE ENROLLMENT IS
DECLINING.
COVERED AREA SAN FRANCISCO SO
WHAT IS THAT MEANS THAT IT'S SO
EXPENSIVE.
THAT PEOPLE YOU KNOW THEY GOT
ACCEPTED THERE LIKE NAM A PASS
YOU KNOW.
I CAN'T AFFORD TO LIVE THERE SO
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND A YEAR.
TUITION FOR SOMEONE WILL STICK
THAT PURSUE A CAREER IN PUBLIC
SERVICE.
YOU LOOK AT THE HOUSING COSTS
THE AVERAGE. ONE BEDROOM
APARTMENT IN SAN FRANCISCO'S
FOUR THOUSAND A MONTH.
SO YOU KNOW THAT'S DOUBLE THAT
AS FAR AS YOUR YOUR HOUSING
COSTS THROUGHOUT THE YEAR SO.
YEAH I'M NOT SURE HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE.
ARE ARE GOING TASTINGS TO PURSUE
A CAREER WORKING FOR LUNCH
COUNSELOR.
SOME PUBLIC INTEREST ENTITY --
BUT BUT WITH THAT AGAIN YOU HAVE
THE DISTINCTION IN THE ENVY AND
THE NOT SO MUCH THE ENVY OF
BEING SINGLED OUT HERE AS THE
LAW SCHOOL.
THAT WE TALK ABOUT THESE ISSUES
ON A AND PRIVILEGE YES.
ALREADY THANK YOU WILL HOLD THIS
ISSUE OPEN.
AND CIRCLE BACK AFTER THE MAY
REVISE THAT CONCLUDES THE THE
AGENDA IS.
ITEM TODAY WILL NOW -- PROCEED
WITH PUBLIC COMMENT ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR ISSUES.
ON THE AGENDA OR NOT ON THE
AGENDA NOW IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY.
PLEASE -- COME TO THE CENTER OF
THE HEARING ROOM.
AND PLEASE KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO
ONE MINUTE OR LESS SIXTY SECONDS
OR LESS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING LARA AS OTHER
CUBITS WITH THE INSTITUTE FOR
COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS WE
ARE ALSO VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
NEEDY STUDENTS PARENTS BUT
BELIEVE A MORE EFFECTIVE.
TARGETED SOLUTION TO ADDRESSING
UNMET NEED WOULD BE TO INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF ANNUALLY AVAILABLE
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANTS.
AS THE ANNOUNCES POINTS OUT THE
VAST MAJORITY 71% OF COMPETITIVE
CAL GRANT ELIGIBLE STUDENT
PARENTS DO NOT RECEIVE ONE
SIMPLY BECAUSE TOO FEW ARE
AVAILABLE.
THE HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO
MILLION PROPOSED COULD INSTEAD
FIND OVER FIFTY THOUSAND MORE
COMPETITIVE AWARDS EACH YEAR
ALMOST TRIPLING THE CURRENT
AMOUNT.
THIS WOULD PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
STATE FINANCIAL AID TO MANY MORE
OF THE OVER THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS
EACH YEAR.
MANY OF WHOM ARE PARENTS AND
MOST OF WHOM ARE VERY LOW INCOME
HE DID NOT RECEIVE A CAL GRANT
SIMPLY BECAUSE NOT ENOUGH FOR
AVAILABLE.
WE ALSO SUPPORT INCREASING THE
CAL GRANT BE ACCESS THE WORD TO
HELP OUR NEEDY STUDENTS BETTER
COVER TOTAL COLLEGE COSTS
INCLUDING LIVING EXPENSES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK TO HELP
NEEDY CALIFORNIANS GET THE
FINANCIALLY THEY NEED TO ACCESS
AND SUCCEED IN COLLEGE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THIS YEAR MY DL REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA LIBRARY ASSOCIATION
STRONGLY SUPPORT BOTH A LUNCH IN
THE LIBRARY AND THE ZIP BOOKS A
PROGRAM -- MISTER LUCAS MADE
REFERENCE TO THE FACT THAT THESE
ARE MORE THAN JUST LUNCH AT THE
LIBRARY -- JUST QUICKLY -- BUT
LAST YEAR WE ASK FOR SOME
INFORMATION IN ONTARIO THAT
MISTER LUCAS ALSO MENTIONED SAID
THAT THEY OF FAMILIES COME FOR
LUNCH AND END UP STAYING FOR THE
DAY THE ATTEND PROGRAMS CHECK
OUT BOOKS AND USE OUR OTHER
SERVICES A PORTION OF THESE
FAMILIES EVERY YEAR A COMPLETELY
NEW. TO THE LIBRARY AND END UP
GETTING A LIBRARY CARDS AND THEN
ALSO MISTER CHAD THANK YOU KNOW
THAT LAST YEAR THE SACRAMENTO
PUBLIC LIBRARY GOT A SPECIAL
AWARD FOR THEIR EXCELLENT LUNCH
THE LIBRARY PROGRAM THANK YOU.
HI GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR I'M
J. GRAHAM OR WITH THE CAMPAIGN
FOR CALLED OPPORTUNITY LIKE TO
THANK YOU AND YOUR COLLEAGUES
FOR REALLY LEADING -- IN THIS
CONVERSATION ON HOW WE CAN
REFORM OUR FINANCIAL AID PROGRAM
TO ENSURE THAT MONEY ISN'T A
BARRIER TO TALENT OR HARD WORK
AND REALLY ADVANCE A MORE
AFFORDABLE PATHWAY TO HIGHER
EDUCATION -- WE AT THE CAMPAIGN
FOR CALLED OPPORTUNITY WOULD
ECHO MUCH OF WHAT OUR PARTNERS
AT TI GUESS -- OFFERED I'M IN
WOULD URGE OUR POLICY MAKERS AS
YOU UNDERGO THIS LIKELY MULTI
YEAR PHASED IN PROCESS -- TO
START BY FOCUSING ON STUDENTS
WERE CURRENTLY NOT SERVED BY
STATE AID AND ALSO HELPING THEM
MEET THOSE NON TUITION EXPENSES
AS WELL AS SUPPORTING TIMELY AND
AFFORDABLE GRADUATION BY.
INSTITUTING THIS SUMMER CAL
GRANT PROGRAM AND ARE CALIFORNIA
UNDOCUMENTED HIGHER EDUCATION
COALITION WHAT ALSO ASK THAT YOU
LOOK AT THAT -- NON FISCAL
CHANGING ALLOWING OUR DREAM ACT
FILERS TO ACCESS COMPETITIVE
AWARDS AND FINALLY ALSO THE
SERVICE INSTEAD OF GRANT PROGRAM
TO PROVIDE THEM WITH AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GET FINANCIAL
HELP.
AND THE ABILITY -- TO GET SOME
PROFESSIONAL SKILLS ALONG THE
WAY.
THANK YOU YEAH.
BETWEEN.
GOOD MORNING BRIANNA FRIENDS THE
CALIFORNIA AND COALITION -- OUR
COALITION IS SUPPORTIVE OF A
COMPREHENSIVE I FINANCIALLY
REFORM WITH AN EMPHASIS IN
ADDRESSING TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE -- AND ASSISTING
THOSE WHO ARE MOST IN NEED AS A
STEP IN THAT DIRECTION AND WE
ARE SUPPORTIVE OF HIS OF OF A
SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE TO THE
NUMBER OF COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT
THE AWARDS.
WE ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO
ENSURE THAT ANY CHANGES THE
FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM AS ASSIST
ADULTS RECEIVING CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION WITH A FOCUS
ON THOSE MOST IN NEED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TOO OFTEN THE CONVERSATION
AROUND COMMUNITY COLLEGE COST
FOCUS ON TUITION AND THIS IDEA
OF FREE.
COLLEGE HOWEVER WE KNOW THAT THE
REAL COST TO OUR STUDENTS IS IN
FACT FOOD.
HOUSING AND OTHERS OF COST OF
LIVING EXPENSES SO WE SUPPORT
INCREASED -- FINANCIALLY FOR
THOSE STUDENTS IN PARTICULAR
THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
HANNAH BRAG START WITH THE CAL
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION --
WE'RE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF ALL
THE WORK ON FINANCIAL AID THAT'S
BEEN -- DONE BY THE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR ALSO WOULD
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR COMING TO
DOCUMENT A STATE YESTERDAY --
ONE TIME WE'D LIKE TO SEE IS AN
INCREASE IN AWARDS -- TO COVER
TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE.
GOOD MORNING.
I SKIPPED THE MID TERM TRAVEL
THREE HUNDRED NINETY MILES FROM
YOU SEE SAID ABOUT A MISSED OUT
FIFTY PAGES OF READING OF
CLASSES FORGET DO MY HOMEWORK TO
COME TO THIS MEETING TODAY. TO
DISCUSS ON TO YOU ONLY HAVE THE
SEIZE THE PROBLEMS THAT WE
DESPERATELY NEED TO BE I JUST OF
ME AND THE THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS
WHO ATTENDED YOU SEE INSTITUTION.
MY NAME IS CHRISTIAN I'M A THIRD
YEAR ECONOMICS AND ACCOUNTING
MAJOR REPRESENTING ON BEHALF TO
DCF NETWORK YOU SEE AS BEING THE
UC'S.
WE HAVE EASY SYSTEM HAVE CREATED
SO STATURE RESULTS.
AND WITH WE DO WORK CLASS
FACULTY AND QUALITY OF EDUCATION
THROUGH MANY STUDENTS WHO ARE
DESTINED TO CREATE AN INNOVATIVE
FEATURE.
BUT AS IT AS EASY WE HAVE
SUFFERED PROBLEMS THAT NEED TO
BE NOTED SUCH AS FOOD AND
SECURITY HOMELESSNESS AMONG
STUDENTS.
LOW GRADUATION RATES IN THE
OVERCROWDED LECTURE HALLS.
AT THE FIRST GENERATION STUDENT
HAS BEEN REJECTED IN THE SCHOOL
THAT I CURRENTLY GO TO BAFFLES
ME THAT WE STILL FACE THESE
ISSUES IN SUCH A WORLD CLASS
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM.
KNOWN TO GREAT INNOVATION AND
KNOWLEDGE IN THE FUTURE I HOPE
EACH OF YOU RECOGNIZE THE FACT
THAT WE STUDENTS STRUGGLE IN THE
MANY WAYS THAT WE SHOULD
STRUGGLE.
IN THE NEXT FEW WEEKS THE
DECISION WILL COME DOWN TO YOU.
OUR FUTURE IS IN YOUR HANDS HOPE
YOU'LL MAKE THE RIGHT DECISION.
HELP OUR FUTURE.
INVEST IN OUR FUTURE.
HI MY NAME IS THIRTY LOPEZ I GO
TO CALIFORNIA LUTHERAN
UNIVERSITY IN THOUSAND OAKS
CALIFORNIA I'M FIRST GENERATION
STUDENT LOW INCOME -- AND I'M
MAJORING IN SOCIOLOGY IN SPANISH
WITH A DOUBLE MINOR POLITICAL
SCIENCE IN ETHNIC STUDIES I'M
HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR TO RETURN
THE FUNDING.
FORMULA FOR STUDENTS AT PRIVATE
SCHOOLS FOR OUR PRIVATE
NONPROFIT COLLEGES WITHOUT THE
CAL GRANT I WOULD NOT BE GOING
TO THE SCHOOL THAT I'M GOING TO
NOW WOULD NOT BE RECEIVING THE
EDUCATION THAT I AM SO FORTUNATE
TO BE -- IN RIGHT NOW AND I
PLEASE ASK THAT YOU RETURN TO
THAT FORMULA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LESLIE MUDDY I AM
ALSO A STUDENT AT CAL IS THERE
AND I AM A DOUBLE MAJOR
CRIMINOLOGY AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE
WITH -- AND SPANISH WITH A MINOR
IN ETHNIC STUDIES -- I JUST
WANNA SAY THAT THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE CAL GRANT SPECIALLY FOR A
PRIVATE INSTITUTION IS REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE TUITION IS
LIKE FORTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
AT CALTRAIN SO WITHOUT THE CAL
GRANT I WOULDN'T BE WHERE I AM
TODAY.
THANK YOU.
ERICA REMEMBER HAVE THE HISPANIC
ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES WE SENT A LETTER
OUTLINING PARTIES FOR HOW WE
STREAMLINED FINANCIAL AID FOR
LATINO STUDENTS.
WHO ARE PRIMARILY LOW INCOME WE
DO RECOMMEND ELIMINATING THE
DISTINCTION BETWEEN COVERAGE AND
BE ALLOWING ALL STUDENTS TO TIME
INSTITUTIONAL THEIR CHOICE
COVERING TUITION?
CREATING A SEPARATE ACCESS AWARD
THAT WE RECOMMEND INCREASING
TIGHTLY THREE THOUSAND WILL ALSO
MAKE THE ACCESS AWARD AVAILABLE
FOR ALSO INTO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
WHO GET A BOG WAIVER -- SO THAT
WE TREAT STUDENTS EQUALLY IN THE
FOUR IN THE TWO YEARS -- CREATE
THE FUNDING FORMULA FOR STUDENTS
IN THE PRIVATE NOT FOR PROFIT
INCLUDE ARE UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS IN ALL FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAMS -- SUPPORT SUMMER
SESSIONS AND ALSO ELIMINATE THE
EACH CAT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR CHECKLIST
RESPONSES WITH TRUE THOUGH THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS ALSO REPRESENTING OUR
YOUTH ORGANIZATION THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM NETWORK WHICH
IS CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST AND
DOCUMENTS STUDENT LED
ORGANIZATION -- MORE SUPPORT OF
AN AND APPRECIATE THE CONCEPTS
TO REMOVE BARRIERS FROM
DOCUMENTS STUDENTS TO OBTAIN
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT BUT ACCESS --
URGE THE LEGISLATURE -- TO
IMPLEMENT THE SERVICES SENATE
GROUND WHICH WE'VE BEEN PUSHING
FOR THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
WITH ASSEMBLY WOMAN THE MON --
WITH A WITH THE REASONING OF
DOCTOR WE KNOW THAT IT'S GOING
TO BE CRITICAL FOR OUR STUDENTS
TO FINANCE THEIR EDUCATION SO WE
WOULD ASK YOU TO DO THAT.
HELLO MY NAME IS A LONGER RECESS
AND I'M AN UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT
AND YOU SEE MERCED THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE FOR
SPEAKING AND FOR LETTING US HERE
TODAY.
MY TIME UC MERCED HAS BEEN
TRANSFORMATIVE AND ENGAGING BUT
WHAT SURPRISED ME ABOUT THE
JOURNEY TO HIRE TO A HIGHER
INSTITUTION WITHOUT STAYING IN
THAT INSTITUTION WAS EVEN
TOUGHER.
AS A COMMITTEE MENTIONED EARLIER
INCREASING NON TUITION COSTS
SUCH AS HOUSING FOOD SECURITY
TRANSPORTATION HAVE MADE IT VERY
DIFFICULT FOR ME IN MY FAMILY TO
BE ABLE TO AFFORD. TO PUT ME IN
MY TWIN SISTER THROUGH COLLEGE
AT THE SAME TIME THIS IS WHY I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT CAL GRANT
REFORM FOR THE SUMMER CAL GRANT.
SO THAT STUDENTS LIKE MYSELF AND
MY SISTER CAN AFFORD TO TAKE THE
CLASSES THAT WE NEED TO GRADUATE
WITHIN FOUR YEARS AND SO THAT MY
FAMILY IS IN FINANCIALLY
PUNISHED FOR BEING ABLE TO WORK
HARD AND LONG ENOUGH. TO PUT TO
KIDS THROUGH SCHOOL AT THE SAME
TIME THANK YOU THANK YOU WHERE
IS YOUR TWIN SISTER GO TO SCHOOL
A UC IRVINE IRVINE MEANS IT HARD
FOR YOU GUYS TO BE A PART.
THE WE WERE TOGETHER FOR ABOUT
EIGHTEEN YEARS YEAH AND THEN WE
DECIDED GO TO DIFFERENT COLLEGES
SPEND SOMETIME APART AND
ACTUALLY TODAY'S OUR TWENTIETH
BIRTHDAY NO WELL YEAH BIRTHDAY.
DID YOU TAX OR TODAY ALREADY HAD
YEAH.
WE HAVE A FAMILY GROUP CHAT AND
SERVICING EVERYWHERE.
THE TEXT EVERY DAY AS A TWIN FOR
HIM -- NOT EVERY DAY USUALLY --
WE JUST CHECK TO MAKE SURE NOT
WEARING THE SAME COLORS.
THE REASON I ASK IS I HAVE TWINS
AND SO I BUREAU YOU THAT WILL
HAPPEN ONE DAY IF THEY DO GO TO
DIFFERENT SCHOOLS YEAH IT'S BEEN
TOUGH BUT ALSO -- VERY OPENING
FOR BOTH OF US TO BECOME MORE
INDIVIDUALS YEAH AND SO THANK
YOU.
A LOT THANK YOU HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
I'M GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY -- MY NAME IS SAMANTHA
ALL MEN AND I'M A SECOND YEAR
UNDERGRADUATE UC SANTA BARBARA --
AND FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR SPEAKING AND FOR
YOUR POSSIBLE OUT OF THE UC
SYSTEM.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO ENCOURAGE
CONTINUED SUPPORT -- FOR THE
SYSTEM TO MAKE -- UC AND CSU
MORE ACCESSIBLE AND AFFORDABLE
TO ALL STUDENTS TO EXPANSION OF
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS. TO
INCLUDE SUMMER TERMS THIS IS
CRUCIAL TO ENSURE THAT MANY
STUDENTS CAN GRADUATE ON TIME
AND WILL ALLEVIATE STRESS
REGARDING AFFORDABILITY WHEN WE
ASK STUDENTS SHOULD BE FOCUS ON
ACADEMICS.
THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING ARE SIMILAR
MCCARTY -- MONIES ARE MOVING ON
THE SECOND YOUR HISTORY PUBLIC
POLICY MAJOR USES BE -- I SPEAK
TODAY TO VOICE MY PERSONAL
SUPPORT FOR SP FOUR SIX ONE OF
WHICH WE EXTEND CALTRANS TO
SUMMER -- AS ELDEST SON OF
IMMIGRANTS WHO CAME TO USE SB AS
A PLACE A MAJOR AND RECENTLY
SWITCHED MAJORS -- I CURRENTLY
FEEL LIKE A HUGE SENSE OF
CONCERN IN WORD THAT I'M I WILL
NOT GRADUATE ON TIME ON WOULD IN
FOUR YEARS.
AND YOU KNOW WORRYING ABOUT
INCURRING MORE DATA THAN IS
NECESSARY AND I AM.
I AM CONFIDENT SAYING TO LIKE
I'M SURE THAT MANY OTHERS ALSO
CURRENTLY FEEL THIS WAY AS WELL.
SO -- I ONLY AYE DESSERTS
COMMITTEE MATTERS JUST CONSIDER
A SB FOUR SIX ONE AS IT GOES
THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE BECAUSE
I FEEL IT IS REALLY.
IMPORTANT FOR ALL YOU SEE
STUDENTS THROUGH THE GAIN
EDUCATION AT THE NEED TO MAKE
BETTER LIVES FOR THEMSELVES AND
THOSE OF THE TWO PARENTS BEFORE
DOWN IN A TIMELY AND AFFORDABLE
MANNER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MATT THE STUCCO
HOUSE -- I'M POLITICAL SCIENCE
MAJOR AT UCSB -- I'M HERE TODAY
TO IMPLORE YOU TO CONSIDER AS
BEFORE SIX ONE WHICH ALLOW
STUDENTS TO RECEIVE ADDITIONAL
AID FOR SUMMER CLASSES.
THIS EIGHT IS NOT ONLY CRUCIAL
FOR SOME STUDENTS GRADUATION
TIME LINE BUT ALSO FOR PRACTICE
STUDENTS LIKE MYSELF TRYING TO
GRADUATE EARLY -- AS A STUDENT
OF BOTH COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA I
KNOW FIRST HAND THE BENEFITS OF
SUMMER CLASSES -- I BELIEVE WE
SHOULD SUPPORT STUDENTS IN
PURSUIT OF HIGHER EDUCATION
REGARDLESS OF THEIR TIME FRAME.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I'M A FIRST YEAR
STUDENT AT UCSD AND ALTHOUGH I
DO HAVE A LOT OF FINANCIAL NEED
AS I HAVE TWO OTHER SIBLINGS IN
COLLEGE RIGHT NOW AND MY PARENTS
ARE BOTH -- LOW MIDDLE INCOME
AND THERE FOR MOST OF THEIR
INCOME GOES TO COST OF LIVING
AND SILICON VALLEY -- I WILL NOT
ADVOCATE FOR MYSELF THEY
ACTUALLY WANT TO ADVOCATE FOR
STUDENTS THAT HAVE MORE
FINANCIALLY THAN ME AND ARE
LOWER ON THE LOW INCOME POOL AND
THAT NEED.
PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE TRANSFER
MOMENT GRANT AND THE HIGH SCHOOL --
ENTITLEMENT GRANT TO BE EXPANDED
SO THEY ARE ALLOWED TO GO TO
COLLEGES -- ESPECIALLY SINCE A
LOT OF GOOD AS HE SEES OR ARE
EXPECT BECAUSE HE SEASON THERE
ARE NOT GIVEN THE GRANT THEY
NEED TO GO TO FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITIES I HAVE A LOT OF
FRIENDS.
THAT CITED GO TO SEE SEASON TO
THE FOUR UNIVERSITIES BECAUSE
THEY CAN AFFORD TO FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITIES AND THEREFORE I
THINK IT'S HIGHLY IMPORTANT FOR
LOWER INCOME STUDENTS TO GET
MORE EXPANSIONS AND ALTHOUGH I
TO NEED.
OF FINANCIAL AID I THINK IT'S
MORE IMPORTANT FOR LOWER INCOME
STUDENTS TO GET THAT FIRST THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING SIR MCCARTY LIVES
AT EVERITT WITH ME COLLEGE LEAVE
CALIFORNIA HERE ONE A I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR FOCUS ON FINANCIAL
AID REFORM AND I JUST WANT TO
URGE THAT AS YOU'RE LOOKING AT
THIS REFORM THAT YOU.
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY IN THE
STATE HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CORRECT STRUCTURAL INEQUITIES
WITHIN THE FINANCIAL AID PROGRAM --
SUCH AS NOT ALLOWING -- MAKE
EXTENDED PERIOD OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL AND AN AGE LIMITATIONS ON
CAL GRANTS A SO WE URGE FOR A
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN A FINANCIALLY
PROGRAM THAT FOCUSES ON COMEY
COLLEGE STUDENTS.
OR REFORM SAID -- ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF COMING COLLEGE STUDENTS
THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S COULD
OCCUR BASSETT COMMA PC STUDENT
AT UCSF AND BIOENGINEERING.
I AM ALSO ON MY FROM UC SANTA
BARBARA SO I THIS COMMITTEE A
GREAT DEAL. FOR YOUR CONTINUED
SUPPORT OF THE UC SYSTEM AND I
URGE YOU -- TO CONSIDER
SUPPORTING THE UC'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL TOMORROW'S HEARING --
IN A PARTICULAR INTEREST TO YOU
SEE SUCH AS THE PRIME PROGRAM
WHICH FUNDS MEDICAL STUDENTS WHO
SERVE UNDER SERVED COMMUNITIES
AND SO IT'S KIND OF A TWO FOR
ONE BECAUSE YOU GET TO BOTH --
BUT IF IT THE MEDICAL STUDENTS
AS WELL AS THE COMMUNITIES WHO
WOULD BE ABLE TO FOR MEDICAL
SERVICES OTHERWISE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S TORY DUARTE I AM A
STUDENT AT UC SANTA BARBARA I'M
A FOURTH YEAR POLITICAL SCIENCE
STUDENT -- I IDENTIFY AS A LOW
INCOME FIRST GENERATION STUDENT.
I AM ALSO TRANSFER STUDENT AND
THIS PAST SUMMER I HAD TO TAKE
SUMMER CLASSES.
AT UC SANTA BARBARA AND I WAS ON
TRACK TO GRADUATE EARLY EVEN
UNTIL I GOT TO THE UC AND THREW
ME OFF I HAD TO TAKE OUT LOANS.
SO I STRONGLY URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE SUMMER CAL GRANT
EXTENSION PROGRAM FOR STUDENTS
LIKE ME WHO.
WERE REALLY THROWN OFF ON TO IT
I ENTERED THE UC SYSTEM BY.
THE OVERCROWDED CLASSES IN THE
WAIT LISTS AND JUST LIKE THE
LACK OF FINANCIAL AID IN GENERAL
THANK YOU.
HELLO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY MY NAME IS ALI RES I'M AN
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT AT UC
SANTA BARBARA.
MY EXPERIENCE IN HIGHER
EDUCATION IS ONE WHERE I'M
WORKING TWENTY HOURS A WEEK I'M
ATTENDING MEETINGS EVERY SINGLE
WEEK NIGHT AND I'M TAKING TWENTY
ONE UNITS EVERY SINGLE CORNER SO
I CAN GRADUATE IN THREE YEARS
BECAUSE I SIMPLY CANNOT AFFORD
TO STAY -- FOR FOR AND ALL THIS
WHILE TRYING TO MAINTAIN A HIGH
GPA POSSIBLE SO I CAN RECEIVE A
SCHOLARSHIP FOR GRADUATE SCHOOL
BECAUSE I CANNOT AFFORD TO CREW
ANYMORE DOT BECAUSE I DO NOT
RECEIVE ANY FINANCIAL AID -- MY
SISTER'S A STUDENT UC DAVIS MY
BROTHER IS LOOKING AT COLLEGES
RIGHT NOW I WAS ACCEPTED INTO A
BUNCH OF DIFFERENT FOR YEARS BUT
MY PARENTS HAD TO TELL HIM.
THAT HE EITHER HAS TO JOIN ROTC
OR GOING TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
BECAUSE SINCE WE DO NOT RECEIVE
ANY FINANCIAL AID WERE NOT RUN
ABLE.
TO ATTEND THE SCHOOLS I'M SO I
REALLY ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE
TO LOOK AT STUDENTS MY SITUATION
THAT DO NOT RECEIVE ANY
FINANCIAL AID AND TO EXPAND IT
NOT NECESSARILY.
NECESSARY HELP TO THEM THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING OF MY NAME IS ROSY
MINUTE AND I'M A CURLING
UNDERGRADS SO YOU SANTA BARBARA
AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF MANY
OF MY FRIENDS.
WHO ARE LOW INCOME AND FIRST
GENERATION?
WHO UNFORTUNATELY BUT THE BABY
BECAUSE OF BECAUSE ALL ALIKE A
LOT FINANCIAL AID AFTER TWENTY
HOURS A WEEK AND AND THAT I WAS
ROSE RESOLVED THAT MAIN CRAWL UP
NOT ONLY ON STRESS?
BUT NICK BUT BUT MAY NOT BE ABLE
TO TAKE AS MANY UNITS AND
CLASSES I FEEL LIKE TO IN ORDER
TO GRADUATE ON TIME.
AND ON TOP OF THAT LIKE THAT THE
LACK OF FINANCIAL LATER DURING
THE SUMMER -- FOR FOR PUBLIC
PLACES STUDENTS -- OF OF OF
THOSE BACKGROUNDS -- AYE AYES
LIKE IT MAKES IT IF IF IF IF
FORCES VAN.
AND MY MY FRIENDS TO LIKE. TO
TAKE OUT LOANS INCUR MORE DEBT
AND AND PUTS MORE STRESS ON ON
ON THE FINANCIALLY AND MENTALLY
SO I URGE YOU TO PLEASE --
PASSES BEFORE SIX ONE AN
EXCELLENT HOW GOING TO SUMMER TO
HELP MY PEERS.
AND MAKE THEIR LIVES.
EASIER AND BETTER THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS THE
TASTE IS STILL MANY AND I'M A
FOURTH YEAR POLITICAL SCIENCE
MAJOR AT UC SANTA BARBARA.
AND I WOULD I LIKE TO THINK YOU
FOR YOUR PREVIOUS SUPPORT OF
UC'S.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO ENCOURAGE
YOUR SUPPORT -- OF FOR FUNDING
OF NON TUITION COSTS AT UC'S.
I KNOW FRIENDS AND I HAVE PEOPLE
THAT -- HAVE A HARD TIME
PROVIDING FOR THEMSELVES THAT
UC'S SO OFTEN TIMES IT'S EITHER
LIKE I BUY BOOKS ARE BY FOOD OR
YOU KNOW IT'S GIVE AND TAKE SO I
FEEL LIKE -- FUNDING FOR NON
TUITION COSTS AT UC'S WILL HELP
STUDENTS TO BE ABLE -- TO TRULY
SUCCEED IN INCREASE THAT SUCCESS
RATE OF STUDENTS SO THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS HANNAH I'M A
STUDENT AT UC DAVIS I THINK.
CHAIR MCCARTNEY AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
BUT I DO URGE YOU TO LOOK TO
EXPAND THE CAL GRANT AS WELL AS
SUPPORT THE UC BUDGET TOMORROW
IN THE HEARING.
WE HAVE A LOT OF NEEDS FOR
HOUSING AND DAVIS I AM A TWENTY
YEAR OLD STUDENT A
NONTRADITIONAL A LOT OF FRIENDS
WHO HAD TO DROP OUT.
COMMUTE THREE FOUR HOURS I HAVE
OTHER FRIENDS WHO LIVE IN THEIR
CAR OR WHO HAVE ASKED ME TO LET
THEM LIVE ON MY COUCH BECAUSE
IT'S BETWEEN DROPPING OUT OF
SCHOOL.
OR HAVING NO WHERE TO LIVE SO I
JUST URGE YOU TO CONTINUE YOUR
GREAT WORK BECAUSE IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE DONE TELL EVERYONE
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
HIGHER EDUCATION WITHOUT
WORRYING ABOUT HAVING A STABLE
LIVING CONDITIONS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI GUYS -- GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS MARSHA BE SURE TO CALL A I AM
A STUDENT AT UC SANTA BARBARA
AND I STUDY ECONOMICS AND
ACCOUNTING.
USERS BECAUSE BEEN MY DREAM
SCHOOL SINCE I WAS THIRTEEN
YEARS OLD BUT WHEN I GOT IN AT
THE AGE OF SEVENTEEN I CHOSE TO
GO TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE INSTEAD
BECAUSE IT WAS TOO EXPENSIVE.
EVEN THOUGH I GOT A CALL GRANTED
AND EVERYTHING WAS THERE I HAD
THE HOUSING WAS SO EXPENSIVE
THAT IT WAS BETTER FOR MY MOM.
WHO IS A SINGLE PERSON TO GO?
TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE INSTEAD OF
UCSB SO FOR THREE YEARS WHEN I
WAS A COMMUNITY COLLEGE I WORKED
FULL TIME AND I SAVED UP ENOUGH
MONEY TO BE ABLE TO AFFORD
HOUSING FOR THE NEXT TWO YEARS.
SO WITH CALL GRAY AND BEING ABLE
TO COVER MY TUITION AND WITH ME
BEING ABLE.
TO PAY FOR THE REST OF MY
HOUSING I URGE YOU TO PLEASE
EXTEND THE FINANCIAL NEEDS THAT
I WON'T HAVE TO WORK IN ORDER TO
GO TO YOU SEE SB -- GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS NATALIE BURNELL AND
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE TRANSFER
STUDENTS THIS IS MY FIRST YEAR
OF MY CURRENT INSTITUTION UC
SANTA BARBARA.
I'M ALSO A MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP RECIPIENTS -- THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE FOR TODAY'S HEARING
THIS IS DEFINITEL VERY
INFORMATIVE -- FOR ME AND MY
FAMILY -- I'M ASKING FOR YOU TO
CONSIDER SUPPORTING THE UC'S
BUDGET REQUEST TOMORROW -- I'M
IN ENGLISH AND POLY SCI DOUBLE
MAJOR WITH THE CHINESE MINOR.
ON THE PROPOSAL HELP ME AND MY
FRIENDS WITH THE SUMMER
ENROLLMENT A HOPEFULLY HOPEFULLY
ALLOW US TO GRADUATE ON TIME
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- HELLO MY NAME IS
ARIANNA MCDONALD'S I AM A SECOND
YEAR STUDENT AT THE UC -- THE
UC'S OF SANTA BARBARA -- I'M
HERE TODAY WITH -- YOU CAN AND
I'D LIKE.
TO THANK YOU SO MUCH -- FOR THE
HEARING TODAY AND FOR YOUR PAST
AND CURRENT SUPPORT OF THE SEA
AND THANK YOU IN ADVANCE FOR
YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT I ASKED
THAT TOMORROW YOU -- KEEP US IN
MIND -- DURING THE BUDGET
HEARING AND CAN.
CONSIDER EXPANDING THE CAL GRANT
TO INCLUDE SUMMER FINANCIAL AID
FOR STUDENTS LIKE ME WHO ARE ANY
BILL -- TO TAKE TOO MANY UNITS
DURING THE REGULAR SCHOOL YEAR
BECAUSE I WORK A LOT AND ALSO --
AND I'M ABLE TO RE ENROLL IN
CLASSES BECAUSE OF THE
WEIGHTLESS AND JUST THE WHOLE --
AMOUNT OF STUDENTS WERE TRYING
TO FIND COURSES THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SAMUEL
ROBERTS AND I'M A THIRD YEAR
PUBLIC POLICY MAJOR AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE.
WHEN I ENTERED HIGH SCHOOL I WAS
TOLD BY MY PARENTS THAT THEY
COULD MOST WOULD MOST LIKELY BE
UNABLE TO AFFORD SENDING BOTH ME
AND MY TWIN TO COLLEGE?
SOON AS I TURNED SIXTEEN I
STARTED WORKING TO SAVE UP FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION AFTER HIGH
SCHOOL WELL I THOUGHT THAT I HAD
SAVED UP ENOUGH MONEY OVER THOSE
TWO YEARS TO PUT ME THROUGH THE
FIRST TWO YEARS OF COLLEGE.
I SOON DISCOVERED UPON AND
MINUTES ADMITTED ADMITTANCE TO
DIFFERENT COLLEGES THAT I HAD
ONLY MANAGE SAVE UP A FRACTION
OF ONE YEAR'S TUITION.
OUT OF ALL THE COLLEGES
INCLUDING OTHER YOU SEE IS THAT
I WAS ACCEPTED TO YOU SEE I WAS
THE ONLY ONE THAT WAS ABLE TO
PROVIDE ME WITH ENOUGH
FINANCIALLY.
WITHOUT IT I WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO ATTEND A FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTION.
WITHOUT THE GENEROUS FINANCIAL
AID I'VE BEEN ABLE TO RECEIVE IT
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO REACH MY
FULL POTENTIAL AND BE WHERE I AM
TODAY I'M THANKFUL FOR ALL THAT
YOU SEE ARE IS DONE TO HELP ME
GET WHERE I AM NOW.
AND I URGE YOU TO PLEASE
CONSIDER INCREASING THE AMOUNT
OF PERMANENT MULTI YEAR FUNDING
FOR THE UC'S SO THAT STUDENTS
WILL BE ABLE TO CONTINUE. TO
AFFORD A STATE OF THE ART
EDUCATION AT ONE OF THE MANY
UC'S THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS ASHLEY POND SAY
AND I WANNA TAKE OFF LET ME
SPEAKER TODAY -- I AM A THIRD
YEAR YOU SEE OUR STUDENT I COME
FROM A SINGLE INCOME HOUSEHOLD
AND I'M THE FIRST IN MY FAMILY
TO GO TO COLLEGE.
WHEN I FIRST TOLD MY PARENTS
THAT I WANTED TO ATTEND YOU SEE
ARE THEY DISCOURAGE THE IDEA
KNOWING HOW EXPENSIVE TUITION
CAN BE AND THE AMOUNT OF LOANS I
WOULD PROBABLY HAVE TO TAKE OUT?
HOWEVER I WAS FORTUNATE ENOUGH
TO RECEIVE FINANCIAL AID AND YOU
SEE OUR GRANTS THAT ENTIRELY
BECAUSE COVER THE COST OF
ATTENDANCE I'M HERE TO THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR SUPPORT AND EFFORTS
THAT HAVE LOUD INCOME LOW INCOME
STUDENTS LIKE ME. TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET A YOU SEE
EDUCATION.
ALTHOUGH THE UC BUDGET IS BEING
DISCUSSED TOMORROW I WANT TO
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR UC
CAMPUSES.
BECAUSE IT MAKES LIFE CHANGING
DIFFERENCES TO STUDENTS LIKE ME
AND OTHERS I HAVE SPOKEN TODAY
THANK YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN PARTY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS MARQUES ABROAD AND
I'M A GRADUATING SENIOR UC
RIVERSIDE.
AND I I GREW UP IN AN ENGINE
HOUSEHOLD WHERE MY DAILY
STRUGGLES ARE LITERALLY FINDING
A WARM MEAL TO EAT -- I WAS
RAISING MY THREE SIBLINGS BY A
SINGLE MOTHER A SINGLE PARENT
WHO WORKED AS A RESTAURANT
HOSTESS AND SERVER -- AND I'M
ONLY HERE BECAUSE THE UNIVERSE A
CALIFORNIA AND MEMBERS LIKE YOU
IN THE STATE INVESTED IN MY
FUTURE.
AND GAE ME A WAY TO PURSUE
SOMETHING GREATER WITH MY LIFE --
57% OF YOU SEE OUR STUDENTS ARE
FIRST GENERATION AND THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE STUDENTS ARE
ONLY AND BECAUSE OF FINANCIAL
AID.
WE MUST PRIORITIZE ACCESS
AFFORDABILITY AND YOU SEE BUDGET
REQUEST WHICH INCLUDES A HUNDRED
EIGHTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS ON
TOP OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
WHICH ALSO INCLUDES THE MULTI
YEAR PERMANENT FUNDING -- I
PLEASE ASK THAT YOU FUND THE UC
AND FOR THEIR SUPPORT INCREASED
FINANCIAL AID -- SO THAT
EVERYONE CAN CONTINUE HAVING
ACCESS TO THE CALIFORNIA DREAM
JUST LIKE I'D THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
GOOD MORNING ALEX CRAZY
ASSOCIATION INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES REPRESENTING OVER
EIGHTY NOT PROFIT NOT FOR PROFIT
INSTITUTIONS IN THE STATE UNDER
NINETY THOUSAND UNDERGRADUATES
IN OVER TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
CAL GRANT RECIPIENTS --
REGARDING ISSUE ONE I WE JUST
WANT TO URGE IT IF THE
LEGISLATURE MOVES TO INVEST IN
THAT MANNER AND SOON PARENTS
THAT -- WE ALSO INVEST IN
STUDENT PARENTS ATTENDING
PRIVATE FOR PROFIT INSTITUTIONS
IN THE STATE WE KNOW WE HAVE
ABOUT SIXTEEN HUNDRED OF THOSE
STUDENTS PARENTS CURRENTLY
ATTENDING OUR INSTITUTIONS MANY
OF WHOM ARE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY -- IN INLAND EMPIRE AREAS --
AND IN TERMS OF CAL GRANT REFORM
JUST WANNA THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
PARTY AND YOUR COLLEAGUES FOR
FOR REALLY THOUGHTFUL WORK -- ON
THAT LEGISLATION AND WE THINK
YOU CORRECTLY IDENTIFIED THE
MAJOR ISSUES -- ANY OF
ADDRESSING AND WOULD ALSO URGE
SUPPORT -- FOR RETURNING TO
EQUITABLE STABLE -- INVESTMENTS
I'VE STUDENTS ATTENDING OUR
INSTITUTIONS TO BE AT THE RETURN
TO A CAL GRANT FUNDING FORMULA
THANK YOU.
HELLO GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
DEANNA GUY GOES I'M EAT THE
CURRENT UC DAVIS STUDENT AND IN
TURN WITH THE UC STUDENTS
ASSOCIATION -- I'D LIKE -- TO JR
CONTINUED -- UP FOR IN SUPPORT
AND I'M WORKING ON FINANCIAL AID
REFORM -- CURRENT NO FETCHED AID --
DOESN'T FULLY TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THE TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE --
FOR UNIVERSITIES -- I FOR MYSELF
AND A LOT OF YOUR FRIENDS -- AND
CO WORKERS AND CLASSMATES THAT
I'VE MET THAT PASSED FOR YEARS
AT DAVIS.
I REALLY HAD NO STRUGGLES WITH
MEETING -- ALL THE COST AND A
TRIBUTE TO TRANSPORTATION
HOUSING AND FOOD -- AS YOU
OTHERS SINCE HERE MENTIONED.
IT'S KIND OF YOU KNOW DOWN TO
YOU KNOW WHAT STATES ARE ABLE TO
PAY -- ABOUT WITH STUDENTS WHO --
FRIENDS OF MINE WHO IT WERE
UNSURE IF ABLE TO EVEN PAY FOR
LIKE A MEAL -- WHEN YOU GO OUT
SO I'M SURE THINGS LIKE THAT
THAT -- REALLY IMPACT OUR
STUDENTS -- SO I HOPE THAT
YOU'LL HAVE CONTINUED CONSIDER
THE TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE AS
IT SHOULD BE A BARRIER TO OUR
STUDENTS ACHIEVING THEIR DEGREE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ON THIS IS POSH ON
THE UC STERN ASSOCIATION -- AS
MAY THE FORCE MENTIONED WE'RE
HERE TO SUPPORT THE EXPANSION OF
CAL RAINY SUMMER SESSIONS AS
WELL AS FOR TO COVER THE COST OF
ATTENDANCE.
AND SPECIFICALLY ONE WAY THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THIS HAPPEN
ALSO IS THROUGH EXPANSION OF THE
ACTS OF WAR -- WE KNOW THAT THIS
TAX WHAT WAS DESIGNED TO HELP
STUDENTS WITH NON TUITION COSTS
ESPECIALLY OF THE LOWER INCOME
STATUS BUT IT HASN'T BEEN TIED
TO INFLATION OVER YEARS AND IT'S
GOT INTO A RESULT TO A POINT
WHERE.
IT NO LONGER INSUFFICIENTLY GETS
CLOSE TO ADDRESSING THE COSTS
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT THE
INCREASED AND ALSO TIED TO
INFLATION SO WE DON'T HAVE TO
COME BACK TO THIS ISSUE YEARS
DOWN THE ROAD.
SO THANK YOU [inaudible]
CHAIRMAN MCCARTY. FORTY YEARS
AGO.
SHOULD WE SAY IS IS MY EDUCATION
EXPERIENCE.
THIS IS MY OPPORTUNITY OF GIVING
BACK.
AND THIS IS WHERE INDEED.
SO FOR TOMORROW SAY IS IS.
I'M JEFF HARDY KIA ON THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE I REPRESENT A NUMBER OF
ORGANIZATIONS AND I AM STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT.
INCREASING WHAT WE NEED FOR THE
FUTURE.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- WE
HEAR YOU LOUD AND CLEAR.
AND WE WILL -- COME BACK AFTER
THE ME REVISE AND REVISIT.
STUDENT FINANCIAL AID AS WELL AS
THE OTHER ISSUES THAT WORDS
AREN'T